foreign
everyone and welcome to the house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly affairs
we have a couple of bills that we're
going to be hearing this morning but
before we do that I'd like to ask
everyone to please join me in the Pledge
of Allegiance
of the United States of America
to The Republic in which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you everyone
the first bill this morning is Senate
Bill 239 and I would um I'm pleased to
recognize the prime sponsor Senator
Waters good morning Senator good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee
nice to see you all Senator David Waters
District 4 to introduce Senate bill to
239 and as you see from the summary of
the bill uh here that it does a variety
of things related to um uh harm
reduction services and treatments for
substance uh misuse and I'll go through
the bill in just a moment but I I bring
the bill before you really as the
resultable out of work
um by members of the of this committee
and uh the house and the Senate and many
others and
um I want to note particularly the harm
reduction study committee that we had
last summer and uh last fall
representative Healy representative
former representative woods and
representative Edwards were all parts of
of that and I had the copies of that
study sent too because the bill really
arises from all the issues that we
looked at in that study but of course
the bill and our a whole response to
substance misuse as a result of
partnership over many years trying to
address these um issues I I do want to
point out particularly governor sununu
you know with the wisdom of establishing
a doorways program and getting a grant
there which is a huge step forward for
the State the commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs Patrick Tufts I'm on that
commission as the several legislators
are New Hampshire providers Association
New Hampshire harm reduction Coalition
and you know recovery organizations uh
you know thanks to the Manchester chief
of police mayor Craig and you know the
chiefs of police in general who have
have worked on these issues and really
out there in our communities on the
front lines the EMTs and and others um
you know I think in the legislature I
think back former representative Hannon
who pioneered needle exchange programs
along with Senator gray and you know
Senator Senator Bradley and you know
members of this this Committee in the
house and um so I I just want to
acknowledge that that there's been so
much um good effort in the state and
that's the New Hampshire way to try to
see what we can do about substance uh
misused disorder the opioid uh crisis
so um it the bill does a variety of
things and I want to start with what it
does in the first few pages related to
the governor's commission Alcohol and
Other Drugs what you see here
essentially embeds the language of harm
reduction throughout the statute for the
Governor's Commission because the
Strategic plan which the commission has
developed over the last couple of years
creates a new area uh one of its task
force groups in the area of harm
reduction so working with Patrick tops
the numbers and other members of the
commission these kind of revisions
acknowledge the newly developed aspects
of the mission of the governor's
commission you'll see also on page one
line 19 that it seemed to make a whole
lot of sense to add the president of New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police or designee to the commission
they're they're very glad to be included
here because they are doing so much work
and you know their leadership on a lot
of the issues related to substance uh
misuse and they'll be a good new voice
on the on the on the committee so this
is what gets us through the first couple
of pages you'll just see the languages
um is dropped uh in in there
um
and then I would like us to if we could
please
um
turn to uh page three and another
important new connections it's made here
relating to the opioid abatement
advisory commission this was set up you
know rather quickly when we received the
settlement funding on the opioid suit
and um that at the time it did not
include a formal process of liaison with
the chair of the governor's commission
and Alcohol and Other Drugs
so this is the language that the folks
on that commission thought would make
sense
um so you'll see here
um the new sub paragraph upon
consultation with the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
provide funding for syringe service
programs which is something that is
authorized under the opioid abatement
settlement so the consultation uh will
be there and this is the same language
as it was put in Senate Bill 32 which
was sponsored you know recommended by
the commission on abatement so that this
kind of ties those up together together
well then starting on the bottom of um
on page three section 10. it seemed to
make sense to put the doorways program
in statute as I said you know command
governor sununo and his leadership
establishing 11 doorways programs around
the state they have evolved they are
receiving about 28 million dollars in
federal funding at this at this point
um and uh I it you know it really I
think makes sense because of success of
that program
um that had become a part of Statute and
the permanent feature of the ways in
which we're trying to address substance
misuse please do note that we amended
the bill in the Senate to make sure that
it is specifying existing federal funds
you'll see that the physical note
suggests that if we lost the federal
funds we'd have to find some State
support but I think the record of what
our delegation has been able to secure
for us in the commitment of Federal
grant funding I I think that that won't
happen but it's important to note that
there's not a physical note related to
this because we are not requiring State
expenditures on that program at this at
this time
then on page four we get more into the
heart of harm reduction
activities that are underway and uh
first off it takes an another look at
the syringe service programs the needle
exchange programs and we heard an awful
lot from the chiefs of police and
particularly for Manchester about and
other cities on the Seacoast and else
around the state that we need to
coordinate better of how the syringe
Services programs are being run I know
there was some legislation a house that
tried to get a you know at this issue as
well and I'm very pleased that this bill
now is good with the chiefs of police in
this version and that that's an
important step forward in that
partnership so what it does is it says
the certain service programs um should
coordinate and collaborate
with other local agencies but including
criminal justice and that's that's an
important way to avoid some of the
problems that have occurred in the
operation of the of those programs
without that that coordination
um and you'll see a little bit further
down on Ice 12 13 the same consultant
and form
Municipal law enforcement agencies
concerning syringe service program and
harm reduction activities it took a lot
of work to get to that language with the
chiefs of police but I and with the
Manchester and other municipalities but
I'm I'm pretty comfortable that we
reached a good good place and how to how
to um you know make sure that we are we
have everybody on board
um with that
then continuing the section um
13 uh you know I remember when we set up
the syringe service program I worked on
that legislation with Senator gray when
we finally got that that done and um
part of it that there was um to prohibit
the use of any state funds and that was
necessary at that time and there were
some federal guidelines about that as
well
um but it seems that one thing you'll
hear if you talk with certain service
providers programs around the state is
that they're really nervous about
sustaining their funding and the certain
service programs I mean my goodness do
we need them disease prevention somebody
gets HIV or hep C we're looking at 350
500 000 or if you have a heart valve
replacement
the wound issues that we're now seeing
um was xylazine and uh and other things
that are you know you know wounds are
extraordinarily expensive to treat and
so a 10 cent needle and some clean swabs
um can prevent extraordinary
expenditures otherwise so that's why it
just it doesn't mandate it just opens
the door to it and you'll see in the
physical note that the um HH Department
of HHS says that under existing funding
we can handle this we can handle this um
but I think it's important to assure the
Syrian service program Community
um that as they provide their necessary
services that um we're not going to let
them fall apart if the grant you know if
there's if they're grant funding and
also they're getting a lot of free
contribution from Hospitals now that are
are letting them put the um these the
syringes they exchange into the disposal
disposal expensive and that the hospital
is saying you can put them into our
disposal stream without charge and
that's a that's a huge help so we you
know we're kind of working so hard to
get this successful and I think this is
important there
um
and then um on section 14 uh we get into
the paraphernalia
issue and I I know that um you know this
has been the subject and I I do want to
thank representative Muse for his
leadership
um and other members of the house for
their hard work on in this area as well
all the harm reduction areas you know
representative Muse and the bills that
they have come uh into the house trying
to get at the this this issue of um
these things and so the way that
um this bill does it is to focus on the
people who are providing the Services
Under
uh authorized under RSA 318 b43 you'll
see in lines 24 25 on page four that
those folks are authorized to run these
programs by HHS
that notwithstanding the language on
paraphernalia
that they can have in possession these
items
so I think it's really important to say
to the folks who are operating the
programs that you're not going to be
arrested because you have certain
supplies
that you are going to be Distributing at
your harm reduction program and so
that's why that's key there in lines 24
to 26.
um then a bunch of definitions so what
do we mean and you'll see drug checking
drug checking equipment
um
and I'm continuing on the page
five supplies the syringes preparation
containers and so forth eligible
activities mean that they can get these
materials
um do the training as needed on the drug
checking
um technical assistance about about them
and then providing them
um
so I just want to pause on that because
this is important because I know that
you've had bills about this uh this is
one that seems that the syringe service
providers law enforcement are
comfortable with the way this one is
done
um the last part of this bill uh
addresses
um medically assisted
treatment and as you may know in this
area that it's been somewhat difficult
to ensure that we have medical providers
who have the necessary training so that
they can do the prescribing
for a medically assisted treatment
it was that you had to get us something
called an X waiver which was an
additional waiver on your prescribing
license that lets you do this kind of
prescribing and depending on the extent
of training you could treat up to 25
patients or you could do more and it was
cumbersome and difficult
for in some ways and really wasn't
serving the population that was needed
now between the time I first drafted
this bill when I was working on the X
waiver issue uh then our federal
delegation got language inserted into
Federal legislation which got rid of the
X waiver hooray so what the bill said
okay let's then go at the issue of
making sure that people when they get
re-licensed get some training and so
it's a very light touch it could be
online training but when you go inferior
licensing and it lists here the the What
professions we're covering with that
that you get the training and um I
decided to go this this way because I I
talked to
um providers you know and doctors in the
field and they say you know if you're
coming through a medical school now
and relatively recent graduate you've
got this kind of training
um about Prime
reduction and about prescribing but you
know that's that depends on the medical
school and a few years ago it just was
napping at all so um this said you know
and I think it's also a light touch in
that it doesn't say the first time you
get a license it's when you go into your
first renewal that that's the point you
can demonstrate with all the other
training you have to do to maintain your
license that you can demonstrate that
you you've done some education in this
area
so Mr chair and members of the committee
I appreciate your Indulgence for my long
introduction of the bill but you know
it's a lot of little pieces in here and
um I want to just walk through it and
I'm happy to take any questions you may
have thank you Senator representative
Weber
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for the walk through
um I just wondered when we talk about
the medical licensing and re-licensing
uh you've got Physicians and surgeons
and you have Physicians assistants
um is there a reason why we don't
include aprns
yeah it may have been an oversight on my
my part but I I thought that I had it
was inclusive of the folks who were
doing
um medically assisted treatment and were
allowed to do so but if I've missed
somebody I don't know
I'll I'll check I will check as well if
I miss somebody that is in an error but
I think I I think I identified the ones
who actually now are authorized to do it
but I maybe maybe we'll hear from
someone behind me
yeah thank you for the question yeah
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman um thanks for taking my
question I asked two separate questions
can I do that sure
so the the first one's a response to
that one I I assume you're already aware
that it's in medical rules that were
required every
um CME cycle to do three hours of uh
training in opioid prescribing or harm
reduction that's already exists were you
aware of that
um I'm I'm not don't know if I saw that
so if this needs to be revised just to
specify towards that rulemaking because
it may not be in statute I mean I wanted
to put in statute that's what I wanted
to do I mean rule making but in statute
is what I wanted to do so that brings me
to my second question
um this is my night job my my day job is
that I advocate for the rights of people
and pain
um
um I've been doing this for 35 years I
wrote the state opioid prescribing rules
um
um I just my big thing is barriers to
health care and harm reduction is a big
issue for us our concern is that every
time somebody comes up with a bill like
this
that my people get neglected and in the
end they get harmed I just got back from
Dallas
um speaking with a group of about a
hundred patients who are very angry
um what I think would help legislation
like this is that we have to realize
that there are people that actually
benefit from opioids and that um about
16 million at least benefit from
long-term opioid therapy including
people at end of life
and they always get left out of these
committees and I would suggest that um
I'm curious what your thoughts are that
we put people that are actually affected
by pain on these committees so that they
can advise them about harm reduction and
how the bills are actually could be
better designed so they don't harm them
well thanks for your um your questions
and um
you know I think the intent here uh is
to I mean I know we have things in rules
but I've been on I was on gel car for
many years and I know that there was a
desire throughout gel car's proceedings
that if something in rules is in rules
we ought to have legislative
authorization for that and so that is
part of why
the this is specifying in legislation if
the committee has some wisdom about how
to change that or whether it's necessary
you know uh you know if you have some
consultation with folks who are working
on this then then fine
um on your earlier point
I can't speak for the Governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs I
think it would be useful to talk with
Patrick Tufts if you have some thoughts
in that area I will say having worked on
the Strategic plan and being on the
commission and being on the task force
that's related to this area
that the idea of the task force is that
it talks with everybody and so that you
know it's a pretty big commission
um and a lot of people in various
communities are represented there
um and there's nothing that prevents the
commission
um from talking with the folks that
you're including even if they're not
officially on the commission but I I
think that's a conversation to have with
the with the chair Patrick Tufts just as
a quick follow-up sure I I'm actually
the vice chair of the opiate abatement
commission I bring this up at every
meeting so excuse me I was referring to
the commission on alcohol we interact
with each other so I mean I'm on a
commission alcohol on other drugs I mean
the opioid abatement commission is its
own thing and I respect that what I was
referencing to was the commission
Alcohol and Other Drugs and that I mean
you know the other commission if your
commission wants to do something in
context of this bill great but I was I
thought you were referring to the other
one yeah thank you thank you thank you
representative Palmer
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question first thing is I just
wanted to say that I was really pleased
to hear you talk about the um harm
reduction I I've been taking care of too
many people with long-term wound
infections and
um a recent heart valve replacement in a
29 year old and obviously that's a huge
cost and and a huge use of resources my
question is really nitpicky though which
is
you're asking that the audit by the New
Hampshire Medical Society of those
continuing medical education
um
credits be done annually where our
licensing is every two years and I'm
just thinking of how small an agency
the medical society is and whether that
ought to be every two years as we're
renewing yeah thanks for your question
um that is existing statute yeah so what
I what this bill does is just the Bold
there on lines 31 to 33 and I I so I
gotta plead my ignorance about the audit
issue because of this existing statute
if it's already in statute I'm sure they
would have complained about it already
thank you
thank you representative King
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking questions
a harm reduction I I couldn't find a
specific definition of exactly what harm
reduction is within this bill so I
apologize if I miss that but I'm also
curious is the harm reduction only
intended for the drug misuser or is it
for society as a whole my concern is is
that this legislation is going to or is
patterned after what we're seeing around
a lot of the country where we've we've
been bending over backwards for
quote-unquote harm reduction for the
drug misuser but society as a whole is
just being ravaged by needles being
littered in the streets people
defecating in the streets homelessness
violence I mean and my concern is is is
is do you see any chance that we're
going to turn in to a lot of these other
blue cities
as a result of something like this thank
you yeah thanks for your question and I
really appreciate that because I think
what you're getting at is the kind of
interlinking of the issues that people
are are facing because certainly
substance misuse mental health disorders
homelessness
go down the line and you talk to the
people you know law enforcement or
service providers in the streets and
they'll tell you how
there are many factors here
um
in terms of you know in terms of this
bill it does kind of necessarily look at
harm reduction through the lens of
substance misuse disorders now I've
talked a bit about you know opioids and
so on but the governor's commission
Alcohol and Other Drugs is really quite
comprehensive in what it looks at that
you look at the doorways program people
can present there with many many
different kinds of substances
um that that are there so the harm
reduction does necessarily in this
context focus on the substance misuse
um but
to your larger Point
um you know
harm reduction wants to keep people
alive
and you know some in the recovery
Community myself for 40 40 some years
now
um you know it's really stuck with me
that you can't go into recovery if
you're dead
and so that
um the notion here is that these harm
reduction services
provide an access point
and if you go out and you go with one of
the Vans or go to the parking lot in
Nashville where you know wherever these
services and you and you watch observe
how it's being done that there's a kind
of a check in there Wellness you know
the naloxone is given maybe some needles
exchanges so maybe some other supplies
but that becomes a relationship
and people who engage in harm reduction
programs
um have a vastly higher percentage of
then enter in recovery
um and being more successful in their
recovery program and that starts to help
address the larger issues is that you're
you're talking about I will also point
to Governor sununu's leadership you know
we're trying to address this but look at
all the work that is being done in
housing
look at all the work that's being done
on Mental Health
you know these are these are complex
problems I I think we can do some good
thank you for your question
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
bringing this bill to us I have two
questions around the funding aspects if
I can ask those my first would be if you
know what the level if it's a percentage
or a dollar figure that the federal
funding is currently for the doorways
program
and if you don't know the physical note
says 20 28 million and is that is that
done at a percentage basis do you know
is it paying for the entire program
right now yes it's a grant funded
program thank you and then my second
question is on the syringe funding
um would prioritizing that for use of
the opioid abatement fund be something
that was logical in your mind as opposed
to just going straight to General funds
well that's the question see we got a
settlement that puts I don't have the
the millions in my head but we've got a
specialist of settlement and it may not
be the last settlement we get from the
industry for the lawsuits that we
brought forward
and um so the decision was made wisely
let's put that in the fund a separate
fund and establish the
committee that would um decide how best
to spend those funds you know smart move
from the governor you know I mean that
was the way to do it uh and from the
legislature too I mean you know good
good move
um to do it that way and um so the
priorities in terms of how that funding
goes out are set by the opioid abatement
Commission so um that's really I think a
very appropriate way
um that's that it could determine
working with the governor's Commission
on Alcohol and Other Drugs to figure out
if proposals come forward to the the
abatement commission how much money
they're going to put out and that can be
coordinated with the amount of money
that is being put out through the
governor's commission potentially from
federal grants so
um this is not this is not um require a
certain amount it it this is enabling
just one follow-up sure and then um
reading between the lines it seems that
this is sort of a partner Bill to Senate
Bill 32 which is the one about that so
looking at the two of them together
would make sense yes thanks for the
third um Senate Bill 32
um deals with several issues related to
the um opioid abatement commission and
um so I wanted to make sure because I
had a little different language and so I
worked with the sponsors of that bill to
make sure that in both both bills that
we've got the same the same language and
that's that there that that this
language suggested by the opio Boyd
abatement commission to do it in this
bill to have it like that
other questions representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
for the longest time it seems to me that
um
you know our state strategy for dealing
with the terrible problems with
substance misuse and overdose deaths
have been
um you know the strategy follows the
money so a grant comes we create a
program the grant goes away the program
closes and I'm wondering if
um putting the doorways into statute and
um
taking the saying the money that goes
towards harm reduction can come from the
general fund is this move us any closer
to having a new hampshire-based
long-term strategy to deal with this
problem I I don't know that it's been
tremendously successful but it's um
certainly we've moved forward with
having a
a long-term strategy based on what the
state needs so is this
um concretize that thanks for your
question and you know uh when when any
kind of emerging problem or crisis
develops there are a lot of things that
are tried some work some don't and I
think that for the federal government as
well that you know maybe the grant
funding didn't address certain things
and I think that
that they've gotten better at this you
know they understand Federal money has
to come into these programs but what's
going to work and what doesn't
um and I think that's why I argue that
the demonstrated success of the doorways
so the New Hampshire's tried a lot of
things right we have we have a lot of
you know law enforcement Grant and
Hammer we've done that we've uh worked
with the feds on certain things we've
we've tried with the medical society
providers prescribed with the recovery
organizations you know recovery housing
we're trying a lot of things but I think
what's emerging through the Strategic
plan of the governor's commission
alcohol the drugs and I and it's not
very long I really recommend it because
it took a couple year process to say
where are we
um what's succeeding and strategically
how do we move forward and reorganize
the commission with that Focus now
including harm reduction so
um I I think that that that's why I put
it in the bill on the doorways that you
know the consensus was from HHS and
other folks that
um this is going to be a long-term
long-term feature and one in one version
or another because it can evolve we're
going to need something like the
doorways but we need a point of access
for programs that people can go to and
get the help they need and be sent to
the places that can give it and that
that to me is an important model here
and there and the doorways program is
really willing to you know expand to
other places and expand its Mission as
needed and as appropriately funded
because
we need them we need them thank you
representative Naval thank you Mr
chairman thanks again for taking yet
another my question
um one of the things I was struck with
as I was reading through the bill was
that um the word misuse was abuse was
xed out misuse was put in and
um it's a relatively another sensitive
subject to me but I'm just curious why
that was done
thank you um that really throughout was
at the advice of HHS because this is the
term
um that is now generally in use among
providers and uh and others so that
that's why
um you know I remember when it used to
be the other the other term
um several years ago and now this this
is what the field says is the
appropriate language to use so that's
why HHS recommended we do that I'm a
sorry I'm making faces they both terms
have value and they're not the same
thing that's why I brought it up so here
we are
um I I hear you representative McLean
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
um harm reduction following on
representative King is a is a very broad
term
um and so as a newer member of the
committee I kind of struggle as to you
know where it begins and where it ends
it has some implied definitions in the
bill itself so I'm just trying to get a
feel from you where do you kind of
Envision if the uh if the doorways
program is now empowered to to go down
this path as well they're going to be
getting into housing assistance I mean
so which could be considered potentially
harm reduction so what do you maybe see
as the scope of it or do you not have a
full feel for that yet and waiting for
the commission to kind of do some of its
work
um thanks for the question and you know
if the you're so right you know my lens
is like this that I've been so involved
with it and I you know back it up and
saying do we need and do we need in
statute or harm reduction definition I'm
not sure we do but there are definitions
out there and certainly that was what
was motivating the
um Governor's commission and changing
its mission to include it was a kind of
a consensus over what it meant in this
context now as you know representative
King's good question about harm
reduction can mean you know every
everything every ill that besets our
society we've got to reduce the harm of
it right and I get that you know but I
think that in this context we're talking
about an acceptance kinds of practices
that reduce the harm that is involved
with substance misuse so that's what
we're focusing on and these practices
new ones evolve but there are many many
practice harm reduction can be
needle exchange
it can be wound kits it can be safe sex
kits
um it can be clean water
it can be bandages it can be naloxone
but see the context there is for how do
you reduce harm for people substance
misuse disorders so that's I don't know
if I'm answering your question but
that's the that's the surrounding logic
so is the intention then that the
commission which kind of fleshed out a
little bit as it goes forward bring that
back to the budget task force and then
that would get some kind of further
review later on I'm just kind of trying
to understand what the trajectory is on
this thing yes thanks for the question
um and I'm sorry I didn't provide it to
you but I could you know you can go
online to hhs's website and go to the
governor's commission and you can you
can take a look at the Strategic plan I
said it's not terrifically long so it's
it's very readable and you will find a
lot of your coincidence your questions
answered there in terms of funding what
the governor's commission is responsible
for in statute is that the federal
funding we get and other state funding
um you know is kind of brought is is
distributed
through a grant making process that is
supervised by the governor's commission
so the governor's commission you know
makes the recommend it gets the grant
applications it makes it you know from
lots and lots of programs all around the
state and it apportions you know it
apportions out the funding that it has
so harm reduction would be in that
context of applications for use and and
the available funding
and so forth now the other issues about
housing and these things I mean there
are other folks working on that um but
that's not appropriate for the
Governor's commission alcohol that other
drugs so so not within that okay thank
you very much
other questions yes representative
elberger
thank you very much Mr chairman
um
thank you for this excellent
presentation
um and just one quick comment having
started my work in addiction treatment
as working in an alcoholism treatment
agency where other drugs were not
connected I really appreciate that
instead of saying alcohol and drugs the
language here is Alcohol and Other Drugs
because they are all in fact drugs
um
I'm not sure
in ways and means we spent a lot of time
working on the cannabis bill
and I'm wondering how
some of the provisions in here about no
harm and and treating harm
preventing harm connect with any of the
provisions that are coming up in that
bill
um thanks for your question the doorways
program
um does address folks who have issues
with uh with cannabis and really
comprehensively any anything that
somebody presents with you know we're
seeing a lot of a lot of increased meth
around right now
um so whatever you present
with at the doorways program you'll you
will be referred to appropriate services
so that's that's another reason that
whatever emerges it's it's ready to take
it on and that's what harm reduction is
about whatever emerges how can we help
reduce harm
thank you thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome and I'll say Mr chairman that a
lot of the kind of inner workings of how
HHS and these programs work we're good
folks back here that um actually know
what they're talking about someone from
HHS has signed up to testify so yeah
other questions for the senator
seeing no other questions thank you I'm
sorry yes representative kofault
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question so
um this my question has to do with the
section on page four that is uh stricken
out use of general fund shall be
prohibited unless otherwise appropriated
is it
so so I know
um representative Leon asked a question
about General funds before is this
primarily because opioid abatement trust
funds
are you know fit that description and in
order to spend those we need to
uh we need to strike this this language
from statute or is this a general
intention that you know we're going to
expand
the the program and and sort of not let
Federal funding or opioid abatement
funding uh or the the existence of that
funding or the the uh non-existence that
funding prevent us from continuing with
these programs I'm just thanks for your
question and um the opioid abatement
funding is in a fund it's not general
fund right so that that is not what is
directly here
uh just a little bit of history when you
know it took us two two try two times
two tries over two sessions to get the
needle exchange program and we didn't do
that until I don't know it was 2016-17
whereas
a lot of other states have done it
starting in the 80s and 90s and I hate
to think of the cases of HIV and Hep C
that you know
during that period but there we were
to get that bill passed
and there's a lot of resistance at the
time for all the reasons you might
imagine it was important to have that
provision in there
I think that people have seen over the
last few years the necessity of these
programs and while so this bill is not
appropriate anything from General funds
it just say that a future legislature
would not have its hands tied if it
seems appropriate
to include some State funding to support
syringe exchange programs so that's
that's precisely why just striking that
means that future legislatures in the
budget can have the option if they think
that that's a good idea
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you so
much and I'm available there are more
questions that's okay great thank you
representative Weber
just before you go on it might be useful
for all of us to note that this is an
early Bill and it will go to I assume to
finance afterwards my understanding is
thank you
I also signed up to speak is genio
Higgins from the Department of Health
and Human Services
for three minutes and that's that's
usually the rule for people testifying
so thank you
hello there thank you so much chair and
members of the committee my name is
Jenny O Higgins I'm a policy Analyst at
the department for Health and Human
Services and Behavioral Health and your
legislative liaison for these topics so
I just wanted to make sure to speak
today to this bill and the department is
in full support of the bill it makes
many appropriate language changes based
on best practice in the field as well as
adding the potential of additional
services and codifying existing services
in the state that are critical to
reducing substance use disorder and any
Community harms Associated and what I
did want to comment on today is that
there is an attached fiscal note
worksheet which was submitted back in
February and since that time our
concerns have been corrected in the
amendment and working with Senator
Waters and so we you know have not had
an opportunity to update that fiscal
note worksheet but the piece here that
really was concerning initially was
around making codifying the doorway
system that was is all stood up through
Federal funding and as you've heard
already that state opioid response Grant
is on a two-year cycle and the state
does have to reapply every two years so
we're currently in the third iteration
of our state opioid response Grant and
it does end September 30th 2024 and the
state will reapply again we're currently
receiving that 28 million dollars per
year on those two-year cycles of which
the doorway program is approximately 11
million dollars additionally we have
five staff members that oversee that
state opioid response program and
continue to monitor those contracts and
so our concerns had just been that
financial burden without that funding
the funding is based on a federal
formula which is really based on two
specific data points one is the state's
proportion of drug overdose deaths per
the CDC and the other is the state's
proportion of people who meet a
diagnostic criteria for dependence who
report not having received treatment
which is from the national survey on
drug use and health and that those
formula funds can change in each
two-year cycle of the state opioid
response Grant so our concern would be
having less funding but needing to run
the same program I think the way that
the language has changed both says that
with availability of appropriate funding
we can run this program the other thing
that it does is that we actually change
just the very specific nature of how the
doorway was defined to actually talk
more about substance use disorder access
points which we will intend to to have
you know fully Behavioral Health crisis
system through all of our work in our
long-term planning that may or may not
include those Federal funding formulas
so to the point that was a question that
was asked earlier about sort of longer
term sustainable funding and how New
Hampshire will do this work this
language change gives us more
flexibility to make sure that we
continue to integrate our substance use
disorder care within our mental health
behavioral health system and Primary
Care in long-term term
thank you I'm happy to take questions
and any perfect timing yes any questions
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I want to I hope if you're not
the right person let me know but I do
want to get back to that same question
about
abuse versus misuse
um
to me it's an incredibly important
distinction and in the controlled Drug
Act it's actually abuse of defined
misuse is not defined harm reduction is
not defined
um I'm just curious from hhs's point of
view why it was important to make that
change
absolutely thank you for your question
so people who expect stigma are less
likely to access treatment and less
likely to to be retained in treatment
and go on to get well right so our words
and language have a significant impact
on how people see themselves and how
people see themselves has a significant
impact on whether or not they access
care and so are we we've done a lot to
best practice language changes in order
to make sure that we're doing stigma
reduction so the term abuse was found to
have a really high association with
negative judgment or punishment and so
the term misuse or use that is it allows
for an even more broad thinking than
addiction or a substance use disorder so
substance use disorders are on a
spectrum and opening that more broadly
allows us to also fund prevention and
early intervention and to treat people
long before they may even experience a
full substance use disorder but that
meets diagnostic criteria
so this is my concern
um
in my my knowledge base is primarily
opioids
um so I'm going to limit it to that but
we know that there's 11 million cases of
misuse per year
um 70 of those is defined by the CDC are
actually functionally self-medication
people are misusing because they're not
getting access to treatment for pain or
whatever
um that's where I'm struggling with the
distinction and I get the stigma thing
totally
um
um but I think we're dealing with two
separate issues and I just it may open
up greater doors for us but it may also
restrict doors for us too
um opening I I probably should explain
that right no do you have a question
yeah I want to under I
I'm I'm still trying to understand you
know how this is gonna help when when it
seems to me that
that 70 of people is going to be harmed
by this kind of Distinction
I think that's something where I'd be
happy to work with you offline to either
Define use misuse and abuse and how we
think it would make the best sense to
get the work done all right that's fair
we've had this discussion a lot
thank you other questions
representative King thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking questions
um I've heard the term a few times
already today needle exchange program
um but I'm looking through this bill and
what I'm seeing is not syringe Exchange
program I'm seeing the term syringe
service program so my question is in
order to get a new clean needle is it
required to exchange an old needle
simplest answer there is no so the
access to a new syringe allows for a
reduction in um you know all kinds of
medical challenges including infectious
disease endocarditis and so that that
access is not restricted based on
whether or not you turn in
um previously use syringes which you may
not have in your possession
um the change the difference in all of
the language pieces there with what
you've said with needle exchange syringe
Services programs all of that and harm
reduction is that it's broader than than
an exchange of needles alone right
because there is also naloxone there is
also referrals to treatment services
there's making a connection with people
and making sure they have many of the
other supplies or things that they would
need to keep them health healthy and
safe and reduce that harm
may have a follow-up
what requirement
um or requisite
is required for an individual to
get a new needle so for example it's
illegal in this state to possess
you know a hyper needle if you're just
an average person but if you show up to
these service centers and you ask for a
needle
and we give it to you
under the assumption that you misuse
drugs
what requirement
is there on the person to prove that
they actually do have a drug misuse
problem
access to to Health Care broadly
essentially so there's not a requirement
to to be able to receive Services it's
very low barrier in order to help reduce
Public Health harm okay thank you very
much thank you other questions
as representative Merchant
thank you chair and thanks for taking
the question
I want to commend everyone trying to
expand harm reduction in dealing with
misuse and abuse and things of that
nature
but one of the key words in here that I
refer to throughout this document is the
word prevention
so what are we doing to prevent people
on getting on opiates in the first place
I mean how is this commission helping to
guide
non-opioid therapy drug use if you will
to get him into other things that would
be helpful to treating pain because
the old saying goes an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure but
what are we doing on the prevention side
to help the patient first and foremost
not even getting on the trail for opiate
used to begin with
can I just clarify or the with the
governor's commission plan is it
specifically sure so the governor's
commission plan does have significant
amount of prevention I think prevention
could always use more funding I will say
that especially because there's not also
the opportunity for things like
insurance reimbursement on the
prevention side right so it does take
additional dollars to put into
prevention programming to do it well
however New Hampshire has done you know
um a number of different
programs including our Student
Assistance professionals sap program
educational programming and youth you
know coalitions drug-free Community
grants all kinds of prevention
programming and that and there is a
specific report that comes out from the
governor's commission as well that I'd
be happy to provide you with to actually
walk through some of the prevention
efforts and not to say that they're ever
um enough
follow up
thank you and also thank you for the
report
you hit I think the nail on the head it
comes down to is the patient doesn't
have the insurance coverage for non
pharmacological therapy
and I'm just trying to find out from the
governor's point of view of this
Commission
what kind of focus they're trying to do
with the insurance industry to help
patients or maybe fund a pilot program
so patients can seek if you will
non-opiate therapy to help them with
their pain that's what I'm kind of where
I'm trying to go to
because right now the funding's not
there the insurance companies many times
don't either reimburse for it or put a
lot of barriers up for the patients to
get that kind of pain control
so just trying to find out from the
governor's point of view essentially
here what is being done in that Arena
it actually goes a little bit further
than what I was thinking of when you
originally asked about prevention
programming which is which I was
speaking to is much further Upstream
around education for young people and
that kind of thing I think you're
talking very specifically about pain
management Alternatives yeah so that's
something that I can bring back and ask
a question about to try to answer thank
you sure
other questions
representative King thank you again Mr
chair and thank you for taking another
one of my questions I think you may have
been here
um when I asked the senator the question
and that is my concern is that this
legislation is patterned after what
we're seeing around the country and the
results are going to be
um just massive amounts of homelessness
and violence and needles littering the
streets and feces and just a nightmare I
don't want to see that it used to be in
this country that if you prove to be a
harm to yourself or harm to others you
went into the padded room until you got
better and what I see here potentially
is just really kind of the Cheapskates
version of harm reduction it's like oh
we don't want to pay for them to go to
the padded room so we'll just give them
the needles and the drugs they need and
just kind of get them out of our hair Mr
chairman I'm going to object to the
language
my apologies does this seem like a uh a
very Financial uh inexpensive way to
solve the problem whereas the more
expensive solution would be time to go
into the padded room thank you
chair yeah that is true offensive
language and I object to it strenuously
I hope you will rule that it shouldn't
be used anymore representative King I I
please be more considerate
I'm not sure what was inconsiderate
representative Weber um
the use of the term padded room
I'm not sure what the correct term is
psychiatric facility okay
on those terms that's it's kind of slang
use okay very outdated and uh kind of
offensive in today's
Community okay it's very demeaning
so you may proceed with the okay thank
you so the um the way that we're
offering care has actually significantly
changed based on so much more detailed
research so what we know is that
community-based care
has better outcomes and that you know
residential facilities are are needed
for a very small amount of the
population and so I what you're
describing would be a residential
facility I don't think that we're moving
care
um based on a financial decision I think
we're truly moving care into a way where
we're meeting people where they're at to
keep them healthy and well and we're
doing that you know based on significant
research and to provide better care with
better outcomes because people do well
when they stay in their community
okay other questions representative
cofult
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so
um I personally know someone who is a
recovering addict who has benefited
greatly from a methadone program
and so I'm curious to know if if that is
when we talk about when we use the
phrase harm reduction my understanding
is that harm reduction is we've talked a
lot about syringe service programs
um can you talk about some other things
that are incorporated into that
definition and specifically is something
like a methadone program does that fall
under the the the category of harm
reduction
sure so harm reduction can be used very
broadly the way that I think about harm
reduction is that I have my kids wear a
helmet when they ride their bike I have
them you know ride in a car seat I wear
my seatbelt these are all harm reduction
strategies right so it can be very broad
it can be all of the different types of
things that we do to reduce harm it's
bug spray it's sunscreen you know and so
anything that we can do to keep
ourselves and our community members
healthier and reduce fatality ultimately
when we get into this level of the kind
of harm reduction that's being done it's
about reducing the spread of infectious
disease and it's about keeping people
alive so that they have the opportunity
to go on to get well FDA approved
medications for substance use disorder I
would consider treatment
um they they obviously can also reduce
harm so I think it just depends on how
you define harm reduction but they would
be they would be considered treatment
and they would be reimbursable as well
under insurance so that
is how I would personally answer that
question and I think people Define harm
reduction differently
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking this
question
um in regards to the question of whether
people should be treated or be given the
opportunity to reduce harm in the
community versus
um going to a residential program or a
hospital
Etc would you agree that we've already
had a lot of experience with separating
people in an attempt to help them with
their problems by sending people to jail
and sending people to prison and that
that's been a dismal failure
that and during into the criminal
justice system does come with inherent
additional risks and so it can be very
traumatizing for folks and does you know
we now have done our Criminal Justice
System especially in New Hampshire I
think can be very proud of the work that
they're doing to provide adequate care
um and is very much invested in the work
that we're doing with the governor's
commission as well I do though believe
that there are just multiple Pathways to
Recovery just like with every other
chronic illness and that we need to
trust that and respect that people have
a say in their care as well and so in
the criminal justice system it's you
know punitive because you've broken the
law when we're talking about treatment
and harm reduction and we're talking
about access to health care and so it
may be that a medication isn't right for
you it may be that a 12-step program is
right for you it may be that it's a
medication and cognitive behavioral
therapy it may be that residential
treatment I mean we're looking at are
there the the efficacy and the outcome
comes of multiple different Pathways to
Recovery and in New Hampshire we're
looking to support them all
yes representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and taking my question
um you're talking about the different
therapies and we had a discussion on a
previous Bill and did you email me the
breakdown of the evidence on which ones
I haven't no I have not said that but I
do have an overview of the treatments um
available for opioid use disorder and
their efficacy okay that would be great
um a follow-up follow-up um thank you it
has to do with this too
um
so when we're it sounds like we need a
more narrow definition of harm reduction
um
and I'm hearing that it includes
treatment and then I'm hearing it
doesn't include treatment so
um would you say that it's separate from
treatment and that the harm reduction is
solely based on
a current user
treatment aside
who just we're trying to prevent the STD
trans I mean the
bloodborne pathogen transmission and and
infections and things like that
yeah I think the critical
um piece around including harm reduction
in all of this work and writing it into
the governor's commission and the
funding and this bill is that it isn't
reimbursable in the way that clinical
treatment services are so as we
discussed earlier around prevention the
need for additional funding and
diversified funding sources to make sure
that our harm reduction programs can
continue to operate is not dissimilar
from those in the prevention area right
and then when we're talking about
treatment we're talking about clinical
treatment and therefore there is also
reimbursement rates in addition to any
Federal grant funds and things like that
so that's one of the reasons that it's
so important that we make sure we
specifically call this out is for the
reason of being able to keep them
financially viable in the state
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Lauren
McGinley from New Hampshire harm
reduction
if you've asked for five minutes I'd
appreciate if you keep it to three
I will keep it to three thank you
thank you committee for having me today
my name is Lauren McGinley I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
harm reduction Coalition we operate
three of the state's harm reduction
programs I'll clarify very quickly I'm
attempting to change my language from
syringe service programs to harm
reduction programs only because syringe
service programs utilize the word
syringe and we are looking to provide
harm reduction relative to all types of
substance use including alcohol smoking
snorting things like that we want to
make those Services as accessible to
people who may not use syringes but
still need the the support of a harm
reduction program in their life and so
my language gets corrected to harm
reduction program instead of syringe
service program
for the for this conversation I mean
them interchangeably one in the same
um
we operate three of the state's harm
reduction programs we also support
Advocate collaborate and help fund the
other the seven other programs that
operate in our state throughout we have
good coverage I think we could do better
and as we move into communities and help
communities identify and build their own
harm reduction programs we work very
hard to include an advisory committee of
those community members representative
of a whole Continuum of professionals
to help guide our work as we begin to
offer services educate providers
interact with treatment and mat
providers
we look at the Continuum that currently
exists which is prevention treatment and
recovery and we hope to
um
integrate some harm reduction practices
into every section of that continuum
I applaud and appreciate that within
this bill it also gives us a seat at
that Continuum table so now it is harm
reduction prevention prevention harm
reduction treatment and Recovery
um
Senator Waters and the harm reduction
study committee listened to all of us
when we said that one of the biggest
issues that we have in continuing to do
this work is the funding streams that we
have coming into the state and the way
the state is unable to currently fund
these public health programs
I'd like to provide a little bit of
clarification and I'm happy to answer
any questions too if people would like
to revisit a question or need some
additional information
syringe service programs in New
Hampshire all operate as an exchange
some choose to operate on a plus 10
model which means if you come with zero
syringes to exchange and have me
properly dispose of I am able to give
you 10 syringes and that is engagement
the most critical piece of harm
reduction programming is engagement with
people who are actively using substances
so that 10 can then be returned the next
opportunity that they have for again
plus 10. you bring me 10 I'm able to
give you 20.
the better coverage that we get within
the regions that we serve the the higher
rate of exchange the higher disposal
that we provide and the lower numbers
people need to sustain until that next
point of interaction
so I will give an example if a community
has a syringe service program that
operate operates once a week those
numbers need to go up in the amount of
syringes and safe materials like wound
care for that person to prevent
infection prevent the transmission of
HIV to prevent fatal overdose it's a
good start wrapping up please sure
um so as we decide to
um
spread out across the state we look to
those communities to identify how we do
that and what fits best for their needs
so I'm happy to answer any questions
people had great questions thank you
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I noticed when I asked Senator Waters
about whether aprns
ought or ought not to be included in
this
you were moving your head and I didn't
know whether you were saying they didn't
need to be included or they did need to
be included so I wondered if you'd care
to elaborate out loud sure thank you for
your question
um
any prescriber any DEA prescriber is
allowed to prescribe some form of mat
the largest restriction exists within
methadone treatment which still in our
state needs to be administered within
methadone clinics but yes buprenorphine
Vivitrol Suboxone can be administered by
any DEA prescriber aprns are included in
that category so yes my suggestion would
be to add them
I think proposed language could be any
DEA provider DEA prescriber sorry
other questions
as a follow-up
um
would you agree with me that the problem
of just using any DEA provider is that
we need to get it somewhere close to the
APRN
statutes so that they actually know it
rather than having it hanging out
somewhere that they might not look I do
agree with that yes naming all of them
would be an ideal situation yeah
other questions representative Nagel and
then representative Cushman thank you
for Mr chairman I think I actually have
a really boring question I assume your
T-shirt has value
um what does that say
thank you for the question
it says all bodies are good bodies thank
you
but that was the question
I thought she wore it for a reason and
we should know what it was oh no I'm
sorry oh representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking my question
um
uh
sorry got distracted
oh
it is you probably know the answer
because I saw you shaking your head when
it was mentioned
um I believe it's only illegal in the
state for a minor to possess a
hypodermic needle is that correct with
some exceptions yes thank you for
allowing me to provide clarification
um the state of New Hampshire does allow
any person over the age of 18 to have a
hypodermic needle
um I am able to walk into any pharmacy
and purchase them I am able to order
them on Amazon it is legal for somebody
for anybody to have a hypodermic needle
in New Hampshire
uh follow up sure and um would you just
for me step through that explanation
that you were giving
um toward the end of your testimony
about increasing the resources that
you're making available
um can you just break that down again
for me sure you said you bring I'll give
you 10 you bring back 10 and then I'll
give you 20. yeah thank you for that
opportunity
um so yeah so our three programs operate
on a plus 10 model so again somebody
brings me 10 I can if somebody brings me
zero and says I need help I'm reusing my
needles I'm buying needles off
Craigslist for five dollars I don't have
access to clean and safe wound care I
can say here's 10. here's a wound care
kit here's an overdose prevention kit or
what some would recognize as an overdose
response kit so naloxone fentanyl test
strips a breathing mask I can provide
them with a whole kit of services to
prevent infection to prevent the
transmission of HIV and most importantly
to prevent fatality
the more opportunities that communities
get to offer those Services The Wider
net you cast
um
anybody that uses drugs that is trying
to seek out our help deserves to have a
window of time within their life to do
so and so when we have one time a week
to operate it really limits the amount
of quality care that we can offer
someone and so we work with communities
to expand access to harm reduction
Services throughout any kind of touch
point that they may have so that they
can have you know
we call it the Swiss cheese effect some
swiss cheese has big holes and people
can fall through them so we try to
shorten those holes so that people don't
fall through
one more follower
um okay so backtracking to if they come
in with zero needles and you can give
them ten and then if they come in with
those 10 then you can give them 20 yes
and then if they come back with 20 you
give them 30 then where does that stop
um so it is budgetarily limited usually
by the program our programs stop at 150.
um and I want to identify that no person
utilizes 150 syringes in a week what we
have identified there is a person that
is serving multiple people who do not
feel safe or have the ability to access
harm reduction programming in their
Community we have had feedback from a
lot of people that have said a harm
reduction program saved my life and I
never visited one once because I was too
scared because of the stigma because I
was in danger
so when people come and are able to
um just just it's called secondary
distribution when they are able to
acquire what they need and share with
others what they need those numbers
start to really support multiple layers
of infection prevention in a community
representative Nutter weapon yeah are
you all set yeah I saw your hand up
earlier any other questions uh no
representative McLean just just quickly
thank you Mr chair so I'm starting to
thanks to all this testimony mentally
understand the buckets of treatment
prevention and and harm reduction and
you mentioned that you had actually
changed uh your name to New Hampshire
harm reduction to basically say just
kind of clarifying this is what it is so
from respect of the definition is that
how the broader Community really sees
harm reduction and um do you see if this
was if this bill was to become law that
the bulk of the harm reduction activity
For Those portions of the bill would be
around that and that's what it's talking
about is that am I reading that
correctly
thank you for the question yes I I
believe I agree with you this bill is
comprehensive enough that it does cover
our current activities within harm
reduction and it also allows for
expansion within the the regions that I
believe you touched on earlier today
um connection to services for homeless
individuals connection to medical care
for people that don't have it connection
to long-term recovery supports or legal
assistance or financial assistance all
of those things sometimes fall under the
purview of a syringe service program or
harm reduction program because we
recognize a person as a whole person and
accessing that treatment or recovery
option can only happen once basic needs
are met so basic needs do fall into our
category often but this bill covers our
the Practical strategies associated with
harm reduction provision
okay okay
any other questions
say no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much
no one else has signed up to testify on
Senate Bill 239 does anyone else wish to
testify
comment representative Wayan um thank
you Mr chairman um I just spoke with our
committee researcher and she will be
able to provide us more information on
the syringe program and on this
background so that we can have more
information ahead of next week okay
thank you
okay if no one else wishes to testify
I'm going to close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 239 and open the public
hearing on Senate Bill 238 Senator
Prentiss as the prime sponsor and I'd
ask her to come forward at this time
demonic Senate Apprentice good morning
chair McDonald and members of
house HHS and elderly Affairs for the
record my name is suprentice I'm the
state senator from District Five I
represent 15 communities a large part of
Grafton County some communities in
Sullivan County as well as one in
Merrimack County the beautiful town of
New London I'm here today to introduce
to you Senate Bill 238 so this bill
would allow an essential practice in the
care and treatment of mental health
patients established which was first
established under our national covid-19
public health emergency and we want to
have this remain here in place in New
Hampshire
once the national order
Public Health Emergency has fully
rescinded in May so will the ability to
use tele telemedicine Telehealth to
continue to prescribe for mental health
conditions so specifically here we're
talking about the ability of Physicians
and nurse practitioners to prescribe
again via Telehealth schedule 2 through
schedule 4 Controlled Substances only
for the treatment of mental health
conditions this had previously been done
last year for substance use disorders I
think one of the Silver Linings from the
pandemic is that we learned that there
was a much wider use and acceptance of
Telehealth and in particular in the area
of treatment of granite Staters who are
experiencing mental health conditions in
the words of Dr Roger awesome and he is
the he represents or he's part of the
community health centers Coalition and
he actually is the executive director
for West Central Behavioral Services
which has its home in Senate District
Five he is quoted he's quoted as saying
Telehealth has offered patients the
capacity to participate in Services they
may not otherwise have been able to
access this can include older adults
people with mobility issues those who
are housebound due to family needs or
those who lack reliable or cost
efficient means of regular
transportation for them Telehealth has
proven to be not just a convenience but
a welcome necessity
so as I stated in the first part of my
introduction that we're up against a
deadline in May when the National Public
Health Emergency will be rolled back so
the ability for nurse practitioners and
Physicians to continue to prescribe
via Telehealth will will cease to exist
we believe that I believe that this is a
necessity and so does a majority of of
the Health Care community and the mental
health professionals who've come
together behind this Senate bill
I want to make a few points as we move
forward you know again we're talking
about removing a barrier
um and how valuable Telehealth has been
concerns have been raised during the
Senate process that there weren't
patient provider relationships that were
in person and at the we have testimony
from Dr Mary Lou Tyner from the New
Hampshire Psychiatric association who's
also in the community behavioral health
Coalition that there is a requirement
for an in-person visit to start this
process so it's and you know during the
pandemic if we can just separate off
that time it was unlikely that you were
doing in person now it is required that
that kicks off or starts the
relationship in order for this
prescribing to take place I also want to
point out that you are looking at an
amended version that comes out of the
Senate the amended version clarifies the
language or clarifies consent for minors
so it's my contention that that always
existed but the Senate and I support
this wanted to
make sure that it was you know
clear across the board that parental
consent for minors to receive treatment
from for mental health conditions and
particularly prescribing was clarified
um in the statute and you'll also see
that there was language added that had
to do with access to a Minor's medical
records so with that I'm asking for your
um your timely consideration
due to the fact that we are facing an
essential deadline here and we want to
continue to offer this service to
patients who are to have granted
standards who are experiencing mental
health conditions and rely on this as a
way for access to treatment Access to
Health Care access to prescriptions when
necessary so I will close my comments
there I'm happy to answer any questions
you have I do have people behind me who
uh maybe who I know can provide further
points of clarification
um so that's it thank you thank you
questions for us yes representative
Cushman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for being here and bringing
this bill
um can you just tell me again where
um it clarifies that the initial
encounter has to be in person
the initial counter it's not written in
this bill it already existed
so we didn't we did not pull the
language in here but it was clarified by
the Psychiatric association that they
have to have that patient provide a
relationship it exists in medicine as is
it just was different during during
coven that you couldn't prescribe to a
patient unless you had a relationship
with them
thank you for the question
another question just representative
Nagel
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
um I think I read through this bill
about a hundred times trying to
solve my concerns
um and I thought I'd solved them but
then you said something that changed my
mind okay
um back
um I I know it it's the purpose is
mental health but as we know these
medications have value well beyond the
mental health realm and what I'm
concerned about is for me to do my job
is be getting harder and harder because
I have patients that are 200 miles away
from me in Telehealth to prescribe an
opioid is incredibly important I want to
make sure that this bill doesn't take
away my ability to treat somebody's pain
as opposed to a mental health problem
thank you for the question Dr Nagel so
it doesn't take away that ability in
fact your committee has already
considered House Bill 500 yes which is
broader and is encompassing of all of
this so we had these two bills mine that
was more tailored on the mental health
side as a follow-up to substance use
disorder and then we have HB 500 so I
hope that helps answer your question
it helps a lot thanks you're welcome Dr
Diego representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
Senator princess for taking the question
um speaking of House Bill 500 I believe
is heard by the Senate Health Human
Services committee
um any thoughts on where that's going at
this point in time what I'm trying to
get to it sounds like it could be some
redundancy between this bill and that
bill
but if House Bill 500 is moving through
the Senate and you're absolutely right
we're facing a deadline by May 11th in
order for us to not impact if you will
current practice
so what happened on House Bill 500
so thank you representative Merchant and
good to see you this morning House Bill
500 has been heard by the Senate it uh
we are actually well it has been heard
by Senate HHS which I sit on we are not
meeting this week I know that it is
under consideration that we're talking
about uh we're talking about some of the
same amendments that we discussed here
in terms of consent
medical records all of the necessary
clarifications so here's the bottom line
whether it's 238 or 500 and I think
honestly I mean this is my bill but 500
is the better vehicle because it is
broader and I think it does a bet it's
it serves the granite state better so
these two will meet up and I think
within the committee is well aware of
the timeline that we're facing
you're welcome
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I have a a
question and a follow-up my question is
um
I thought or I assumed that this bill
applied to people of all ages but then
it starts off with talking about
um
minor children and parents so
is it true that it applies to
um children as well as adults
thank you for your question it applies
to children as well as adults okay
follow-up follow-up
um I I don't see that this is a full
solution in any way but could this be an
incremental help in terms of the
emergency room boarding situation where
people could actually make contact with
a with a provider by phone in an
emergency rather than go in an emergency
room in a crisis
that's a good question I don't think I
can give a thoughtful answer I mean I
worked in an emergency room that boarded
patients regularly and you know they
have to present themselves in order to
be triaged and managed appropriately the
telephonic uh replacement or
what do I say substitution for that
I'm not clear how that would work given
them tala given there's a few other
considerations so thank you for the
question I'd be happy to think about it
and get and circle back to you thank you
you're welcome representative Weber
and my question is just jogged by
representative Shapiro's question thank
you for taking the question and thank
you Mr chair
um
I was wondering if
um the requirement of an in-person visit
to start the process which is already in
our statutes isn't that the barrier to
perhaps somebody who's in crisis
getting Telehealth rather than going to
the emergency room
it would present a barrier they have to
start with an in-person visit
um
but there are I would really I'd like to
defer I want to make sure that I don't
that I don't mix the two up here I mean
I think that representative Shapiro has
brought forward a reasonable you know
line of thinking about the fact that we
have these crises and we have people
that are boarding and do we would not
bringing them into departments but
triaging them before they got there
actually prevent them from having to be
boarded but receive treatment that's
what I believe we're talking about here
and I'm not sure exactly what the best
way to manage that is okay but thank you
representative Weber just one more time
other questions
so you know other questions okay thank
you thank you chair McDonald it could be
good to see you all again
also signed up to speak is Lisa maccio
uh from the office of the child advocate
I've indicated you need three minutes
and that's exactly what I was going to
suggest
good morning chairman McDonald and
members of the House health and
Services committee my name is Alyssa
massio I am the new associate child
advocate with the office of child
advocate our office is a independent
state agency mandated for the oversight
of child protection and child serving
agencies here in New Hampshire as part
of that mandate we are concerned with
the protection of children and also the
best interests of children our office
had been looking forward to testifying
in support of SB 238 as originally
drafted but unfortunately with the floor
Amendment we are now in opposition of
this bill as potentially interfering
with children's safety and their access
to safe and adequate Care by providers
during covid we saw that Mental Health
Access was enhanced by telemedicine
however we also saw a loss of trusted
and reliable reporters for children
namely schools and health care providers
RSA 169 C the child protection act is
intended to protect children but also to
look out for their best interest we know
that children sometimes have barriers to
reporting unmet needs or dangers in
their home one of which is a lack of
opportunity and trusted in safe adults
Health Care Providers Mental Health
Providers medical providers are one of
those safe spaces and we have
significant concerns with sections three
and five of this bill as amended that by
holding providers to a standard very
high standard of
not allowing a potential offender access
to a child's medical records could
really endanger children currently under
169 C the standard for professional
Child Protection workers assessment
workers and their attorneys with dcyf is
only a preponderance of the evidence a
relatively low standard just over 50
percent to take children away from their
parents here we're asking health care
providers who are not trained assessment
workers not trained to assess the safety
of a child held to a clear and
convincing standard in order to protect
a child's information and medical
records from a potentially offending
parent we do feel like this very high
standard in the amended language would
interfere with a child's ability to
access that safe and trusted
professional knowing that their
information would be protected typically
a provider is a mandated reporter so
they would take that information report
it to dcyf and allow their professionals
to take over from there and they would
also have protection to use their best
judgment when not releasing records to a
potentially offending parent this
language changes all that and we do have
significant concerns for how that would
endanger New Hampshire's children I'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
the way I read through this bill
the onus is placed upon the
provider or
the individual has a record to protect
the record per se the onus isn't on the
parent to go to the court to release the
record is that correct
um we're looking more specifically at
the subsection B3 where the health care
provider is required to determine by
clear and convincing evidence based on
articulable facts when not to release
based on a parent request
the the section before that with regards
to the court was not really something
we're looking at I think there are
probably other agencies that would be
dealing with the court aspect so the
onus is on the provider to defend
themselves
versus that I'm trying to get to is the
parent having the parent has a right but
the right should be governed through the
court in others if the parent goes to
the court and the court says they agree
with a parent with that also not allow
for the release of the record what I'm
trying to get to is a balance between
the child being protected
from an abusive parent
so the parent so it was if the court
determines that there's no issue for the
parent to have access to the record at
least it's going through a court in
order to obtain the access it's not
putting the owners back on the provider
trying to make that determination
the concern is the initial determination
for the provider to withhold the record
in the first instance is a very high
standard of clear and convincing
otherwise they would
I would presume feel they would need to
release the record which could
potentially interfere with an
investigation if the offending parent is
getting that record in the first
instance I think Court action would come
too late
um kind of let the horse out of the barn
we reverse that Mr chair sure if we
reverse that and make it that the only
time the record can be released is with
a court order
it takes the provider off the hook
because they're not having to worry
about what they're trying to do to
defend themselves and justify what
they're doing is up to the court to make
a decision
thank you for the question I think the
language is still not clear as to who
would have standing to bring it to court
who's coming to court and even which
court
um but again I think there are probably
other agencies that would deal with that
court side of it
representative Weber
thank you so have I understood correctly
that you would prefer the language of
the original bill which is at least has
the advantage of being written down
somewhere rather than this language
thank you for the question I think the
original bill with the intent simply to
expand
Telehealth medicine for mental health
purposes the OCA is in support of we saw
during covet just how helpful that can
be and necessary for a lot of people
including children in our state
representative Shapiro so I'm sorry
could I have one sure I'm late here so
is is the issue I'm sorry I didn't look
at the Senate version the original
version is is the issue here that this
is language that was not in the original
version because it has now been included
okay thank you this language is very
similar to SB 253 which I believe you
are hearing next week right thank you
representative Shapiro representative
Weber asked my question okay thank you
other questions
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I just want to be
really clear on
um where you're at with this so are you
saying that you would like
children to be able to access
Telehealth mental health
medication treatment without knowledge
of parents or their consent on a blanket
basis for every child
the office's positions at the original
Bill language is something we would
support I'd have to see what alternate
language you're suggesting the way their
bill was originally written the OCA
would support
other questions representative palazzov
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so follow up on what a representative
Cushman is asking so help me understand
so if you already
have limitations for abusive parents
like what are other situations are
concerned for you is it like
about prescribing puberty blockers that
you want to do with original bill or is
it like
maybe some vaccination prescription and
if parent is
vaccine hesitant so what are other
scenarios
aside from abusive that you are trying
to avoid by opposing this bill
thank you for the question I think the
office is
um concern is with the way this bill
language is worded that would interfere
with the medical provider's ability to
focus on providing Medical Care and
instead be having to worry about
assessing a child's safety when deciding
parents already have the right to access
to Children's Medical Records under the
law it is with certain carve outs this
law
creates an onus on a medical provider to
very high standard of uh evidence in
which cases they would not
release records to a a parent or
Guardian what those specific concerns
would be would be case specific in the
office of child advocate does believe
that should be left to the providers
reasonable judgment not to this very
high standard that would interfere with
their ability to provide appropriate
care to a minor
follow up
thank you for uh taking my follow-up
question
um can you understand me uh bigger
picture so we are saying that most
parents are good parents but some are
abusive for otherwise uh interrupting
with uh what's good for medical care and
safety of kids could the same be told
about medical providers or
is there anything that your office of
child advocate like would try to protect
from cases when there's some
abuse from medical providers
I'm sorry I don't think I understand
your question
it's okay
representative Weber and then
representative Leon
thank you again Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my next question which is
uh
am I correct in thinking that the bill
as it originally stood
made no change in the existing law about
access to Children's Medical Records so
it not only did not further restrict act
it did not expand access for parents but
it didn't restrict access further for
parents either it's simply left
that part of our current statute intact
and allowed whatever could be done
in person allowed these things in this
statute that could be done in person
also to be done by Telehealth thank you
for the question that is my
understanding it is my understanding
that parents already have a right to ask
success under New Hampshire law thank
you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
being here and providing your testimony
both written and in person my question
to you is that it's my understanding
that all these providers are mandatory
reporters and so if they have a concern
about the parent that should be part of
their involvement in the exam and if
they believe that the child is in an
abusive situation or otherwise at risk
isn't that something that they're
already looking for when they're
interacting with these with these
children
thank you for your question I am not a
medical professional so I can't speak to
to specifics as far as medical ethics
but yes frankly every adult in the state
of New Hampshire is a mandated reporter
as I said one of the most frequent
entrusted reporters are Health Care
Providers and their obligation is to
report their concerns to the agency to
dcyf to conduct a professional
investigation by trained um
assessment workers as far as what their
obligations are to record it within
their notes I'm sure there are others
here that could speak to to that
obligation specifically
um as a follower
um as a follow-up
um
I I guess my question here is if there's
been a report made to dcyf wouldn't that
be sufficient to note in their in their
notes that they had a concern about the
child's safety and therefore they were
referred to dcyf and that would be a
more than adequate indication that they
believe that that child was at risk
in in order to not release the records
to the parent yes
I do not believe that's what this
language says clear and convincing is a
very high legal standard and as well as
needing articulable facts and have it
fully documented essentially putting a
medical professional
in the place of a safety assessment
professional which they are not so again
I couldn't speak to as far as what a
medical professional's requirements are
for their documentation
but I used to be a dcyf attorney reports
that come in do not rise to the level of
clear and convincing that is not the job
of the reporter it's the job of the
agency to investigate and in fact as I
said 169 C the standard to take a child
away from a biological parent in an
abuse proceeding is only preponderance
not clear and convincing but we're
asking that medical providers somehow
have evidence rising to clear and
convincing at the outset not a
professional investigator so that
there's a discrepancy there that could
lead to
barriers within that relationship and
harm children
thank you that was definitely more
detail thank you other questions
representative representative Weber
thank you and thank you for the
telegraph representative helper
um
so I have two if I may one I think
trying to get at the number of perhaps
representative palazzov's question
because I think this reporting
although not directly related by the
bill is is very important to it isn't it
true that if somebody anybody a parent
or
um
other medical professionals think that a
medical professional is harming a child
in any way then they must report the
medical professional
presumably both to dcyf and and their
and their professional licensing board
thank you for the clarification and I'm
sorry I didn't understand that initially
again
all adults in New Hampshire are mandated
reporters to the division as far as
child abuse or neglect were concerned I
wouldn't be able to speak to what
ethical obligations that one medical
provider may have to report to the
medical board but certainly all adults
are required to
report any abuse or neglect they suspect
and well and it's not it's not quite a
follow-up but uh with regarding the
issues of standard and proof we have
clear and convincing proof
um and then and that means that you
actually have real am I correct that
that's real and true evidence as opposed
to
the second level which is preponderance
of the evidence which just means that
there's more evidence that abuse is
there than there is evidence that abuse
isn't there is that right
I've probably phrased that in artfully
as the as to the preponderance standard
generally preponderance is just over 50
percent not not a terribly it does
require evidence right um but clear and
convincing is substanti substantially
higher than that to put it into context
as I said 169 C requires preponderance
to take children away it requires clear
and convincing to terminate a parent's
parental rights right oh that's very
helpful and then one final question
which is
and isn't it true that the reporting
level
is much lower than that you just have to
have a suspicion that it's happening and
that requires you to report is that not
true
a suspicion that a child is being abused
to report to require that you have an
obligation to report you you don't have
to be able to prove it thank you for the
question the office of child advocate
would like to believe that everyone
understands the standard to be low you
should always call the division if you
have a concern
uh the child Advocates uh
efforts are to protect all children so
so the standard should be as low as
possible to any suspicion that's why
there are trained professionals to then
investigate and ensure that that child
is safe
thank you very much representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman
in terms of the
urgency
um related to the May 11th end of the
emergency
um
aren't we isn't it true that we're only
talking about schedule two through four
medications
um I didn't I didn't know what those
were really until I checked with our
resident pharmacist and that um
and that most psychiatric medications
will be can be can be prescribed by
Telehealth
um whether we pass this bill or not
thank you for that only a subset like
stimulant medications will not be
allowed to be prescribed I am afraid I
do not have expertise in that area
either I would also defer to your
resident expert for that that is correct
another question schedule two three
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much for taking the time to hear me
so anti-psychotic medication
antidepressants
also signed up to speak is Matthew Hood
from Dartmouth Health control
all right
10 minutes yep
that's this thank you very much Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Matthew Hood vice
president of government relations at
Dartmouth health I apologize for the
raspiness of my voice I'm on the tail
end of a cold
um hopefully I'll it's good that you're
sitting way out there wait I've settled
way over here exactly right um I will be
brief I
um we we support uh Senate Bill 238
um as Senator Apprentice said we've seen
the value of Telehealth including
Telehealth prescribing during the
pandemic and Beyond think about the
context of the workforce shortage which
continues into today that didn't go away
when the pandemic uh concluded
um and with respect to timely access
as I read 238 it enables Telehealth
prescribing for mental health practice
that is
in addition to the current statute which
allows for Telehealth prescribing for
substance use disorder
that's that's where it ends
um
to representative Nagel's question
earlier House Bill 500
um flips the Paradigm and it allows
Telehealth prescribing for everything
that includes
Cancer Care that includes post-surgical
kit pain management that includes
palliative care my colleague was here
last time if you remember for 500 who
was in the palliative care space
and so I would be remiss if I didn't say
reiterate my appreciation for this
committee's work
representative Leon and Merchant in
particular are working on Amendment on
that bill which passed out of this
committee 20 to nothing and then of a
Voice vote out of the house so thank you
for that and I hope we see 500 go for or
come out of the Senate as well quickly
um
what else would I like to add that's
really what I wanted to make make sure
that I reiterated for the committee I
did wanted to speak though to two other
points one is to the
um
the safeguards that exist with respect
to prescribing we talked about uh the
DEA proposed guidance that's that has
come out so when May 11th rolls around
what is it going to look like and the
DEA guidance requires in almost all
situations the establishment of an
in-person relationship with a patient
before prescribing and then of course
New Hampshire statute also required
requires a visit as is appropriate for
the patient or the condition but no less
than once a year so there are safeguards
around this prescribing via Telehealth
that I felt it was important to comment
on as well
finally I will say that for 238 the
consent provision that you have that was
added by the senate in terms of consent
for a minor
um
to be prescribed medication via
Telehealth we worked with the Senate on
that language we're very comfortable
with where that language is right now
and we're happy to
work with this body should it be so
inclined on the access to medical
records component that was added also by
the Senate but which we find currently a
bit problematic in that it's
inconsistent with Federal requirements
as we understand them so I will end
there and happily take questions and
appreciate your consideration thank you
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
now I'm nervous again
um it seems to me critical that um both
500 and 238 pass or my goals aren't
achieved
am I wrong about that my answer to your
question representative and I think
anyone would people would agree with
this behind me if they're going to
testify subsequently
House Bill 500 does everything and more
than what Senate Bill 238 does so simple
238 is great it expect it extends it to
mental health but that's it and so 500
covers a much broader swath of practice
areas
um would P I'm sorry follow up would
there be any opposition from your mind
about adding
um I mean we could refine the language I
think but for pain management to have
that specifically in this bill I I would
I would hesitate to go down the road of
enumerating practice areas in which you
can prescribe via Telehealth to be
honest with you representative I'd be
much rather inclined to do it Hospital
500 did which was to say you can okay in
this situation because you you'll leave
something out with all due respect
you're right thank you thank you
representative Leon and then
representative Weber uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
being here
um so it's my understanding that you
believe that house bill 500 is
sufficient and that this bill if 500
passes is not necessary with all due
respects my friend Senator Prentice yes
I believe that that's correct thank you
she knows that I was going to say that I
think so yeah
representative Weber
my question was asked and answered thank
you
representative McLean
yeah just uh just a kind of a procedural
question do you think there is any way
where this legislation or HB 500 might
actually end up creating an environment
where those folks desire
um the in-person interaction
um may have their access Limited in that
regard because we're moving due to
Resource constraints more and more to
help Telehealth and that you might find
people saying actually we're going to
curb down this and actually it's only
available to Telehealth do you see any
scenario where that might come to pass
through legislation like this that's a
great question thank you for the
question representative my inclination
at this juncture in time is that the
answer would be no
um and the reason for that is because we
want to be patient-centered if a patient
wants an in-person visit they're going
to get an in-person visit if they want a
Telehealth visit and there are many
reasons for wanting a Telehealth visit
we'll try to accommodate a Telehealth
visit it's more about for me we saw a
spot Lake in Telehealth services at the
beginning of the pandemic and that is
consider a drop off and a leveling off
of it since that point in time since the
pike Spike and so for me this enables
access for those who might have a hard
time getting for an in-person or not
wanting it in person but it's not going
to replace in-person care we're not at
that point yet
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee
also signed up to speak is Sam Hawkins
from Nami of New Hampshire
and again three minutes please good
morning good morning
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today for the record my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm the public policy assistant
at Nami New Hampshire the National
Alliance on Mental Illness Nami New
Hampshire is a non-profit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami I'm here today in support of SB
it's no secret secret that New Hampshire
is amid a mental health crisis in New
Hampshire 221 000 adults have a mental
health condition including 57 000 who
have a serious mental illness if they're
further exacerbating this crisis Granite
State or struggled to get the help they
need when they need it due in part to
New Hampshire's Workforce shortage
providers can't meet our state's level
of need through current channels
telemedicine is one crucial tool to be
used in addressing this issue and
increasing access to Mental Health
Services especially in rural areas of
the state as you heard earlier during
the pandemic several emergency orders
were issued which expanded telemedicine
these emergency orders allowed providers
to provide all medically necessary
Services remotely when telemedicine was
passed into state law last year it
contained restrictions on the
prescription of certain medications SB
238 would codify a more expansive
prescribing law for mental health
conditions therefore putting in thereby
putting the statute parts of the
emergency orders from the pandemic
telemedicine expands access to care for
all and is well suited to many of the
challenges those living with mental
health conditions may experience
through supporting the mental health
Workforce and lowering barriers to care
SB 238 would go far in addressing the
Mental Health crisis in our state urge
you to vote OTP and thank you for your
time and take any questions thank you
any questions
okay seeing no questions thank you very
much
also signed up to speak is Laura Condon
from Bedford
and you have three minutes ma'am
foreign
thank you for the opportunity to speak
my name is Laura Condon I'm from Bedford
New Hampshire and I oppose Senate Bill
238 relative to the use of telemedicine
to treat mental health conditions I've
provided a couple of handouts for you
this bill will permit Physicians
surgeons and nurses to prescribe
schedule 2 through schedule four drugs
drugs considered Dangerous by the U.S
Drug Enforcement Administration your
correct representative Shapiro that
other drugs still could be prescribed by
a Telehealth but these are scheduled
dangerous drugs for very good reasons
um
these controlled drugs can be very
dangerous even deadly to the person
prescribe the drug their family members
schoolmates and co-workers people who
seek these drugs should be carefully
evaluated monitored in person
this is not the time for Telehealth it
is dangerous one face-to-face visit for
children is neglect
more monitoring is needed children and
this is is no limit this could be
infants toddlers you know preschool
children There's No Limit here they
develop at a very rapid rate we we owe
them the requirement that they be seen
more frequently than one established
visit and then additional drugs in a
cocktail and dosages up and down can be
done simply by a Telehealth these
scheduled and the handout it provided
you is from the diversion control
Division and it shows the scheduled two
three and four drugs so that you could
be more familiar with them these are
drugs that have high potential for abuse
and may lead to severe psychological and
physical dependence and include such
drugs as oxycodone fentanyl morphine
amphetamines such as adderall
methamphetamines methylphenidate and
phenobarbital
for your information phenobarbital is a
sedative that slows the activity of the
brain and nervous system and is commonly
used to euthanize pets and since 2010 14
states have used phenobarbital and state
executions these are very dangerous
drugs
just how dangerous are these
prescription mind-altering drugs well
they're deadly in fact in January of
this year there was a woman she was a
nurse Nancy Clancy in Massachusetts you
may recall that she strangled her three
young children slit her wrists slit her
throat jumped out a window paralyzed
herself she killed her children this was
not some sort of street drug addict this
is a well-respected nurse who in
postpartum depression was prescribed a
cocktail of 13 different drugs it made
her crazy her children are dead lives
are ruined the risk of suicide in
Children and adolescents being treated
with antidepressants as well established
science the Food and Drug Administration
requires Black Box warnings and have
expanded that warning over the years
monitoring of children requires
face-to-face in person interactions and
observations that cannot be done via
Telehealth as many who are treated for
depression are prescribed a cocktail of
drugs that would include the mix of the
class of drugs included in this bill
provisional data from cdc's own records
show that during Telehealth there was a
four percent increase I'll wrap it up
four percent increase in suicides during
this period of time clearly Telehealth
is not working
this bill neglects to protect children
from aggressive and dangerous
prescribing of ever-changing cocktail or
psychotropic drugs shamefully only
requiring consent from a parent once
irrespective of how many prescription
doses are changed or new drugs are added
to this cocktail there is no evidence of
safety of these cocktails of drugs I
proposed in the handout an amendment
that would provide protection for minor
children and I ask that you carefully
consider that I think we owe our
children protection of these scheduled
drugs we recognize that mental health
treatment should be more readily
available there are many safe methods of
treating including counseling Behavior
exercise even
um please wrap up yep to improve health
I urge you to oppose Senate Bill 238 as
written or men it will protections for
children thank you very much for your
time happy to address any questions
thank you representative Shapiro thank
you Mr chairman
thank you for taking the question um I
really share some of your concerns about
um people being over medicated having
multiple medications
especially children
um
I don't know of any evidence to say that
that has been done more
over Telehealth than in in-person visits
in fact you know my experiences with a
lot of people a lot of children and
adults who have mental health issues
who've been put on
a myriad medications
um
through in-person visits so I'm not
really sure how the issue of Telehealth
or not Telehealth is related to those
concerns thank you very much for your
your concern
um and you know there was and I I have
it in the handout that the the CDC does
report you know higher incidence of
suicide during this period where we've
used in Telehealth you know is there
something exactly points to Telehealth
itself
um as being you know the pivotal change
here you know we've got this nurse who
who killed her children you know on 13
different psychotropic drugs I I think
it's it's very clear that we we would
want more monitoring of children not
less in spite of the fact if we haven't
done studies yet it just makes sense
they need to be carefully monitored in
person thank you
thank you other questions
representative Palazzo
thank you Mr Chan thank you for taking
my question can you a little bit uh
expand on monitoring and on benefits of
in-person
monitoring versus uh uh
telemedicine monitoring maybe there are
some situations when telemedicine would
be better if if the doctor can spend
more time chatting with a client or or
do you think that certain side effects
from medication
and certain mental health conditions
could be
detected only in in person visits thank
you thank you representative I I think
if I understand your question
um you know what are the the benefits of
of in-person you know versus Telehealth
and when I first looked at Telehealth I
thought well it's a zoom meeting right
so the doctor actually gets to see them
if you look at the definition of
Telehealth you know it doesn't have to
be and in testimony I was on the Senate
side you know it could be an email it
could be a text message so there's
there's no visual contact
um with the patient necessarily via
Telehealth and we all know we've done
the zoom
um and even with zoom we all know that
there's something really different about
sizing up a person
um and and to evaluate you know how
they're doing when you actually get to
see them in person you know is this
child looking really tired are they
disheveled or they actually believe in
to get to the appointment
um you know is there life in chaos and
those things I think you know you get
better sense of those when you see
someone in person you know is it the
parent pushing for this you know to try
to control their child just a lot of
information can be gathered from those
in-person visits to protect children
thank you
thank you other questions representative
farmer
I guess my concern would be this
um during the
during covid and during bad weather the
choice often is a visit or no visit not
Telehealth versus an in-person visit so
I I you know I I guess I would just
like a comment I mean obvious
wouldn't a Telehealth be visit
Telehealth visit be better than no visit
at all
um I I think if there's a crisis
situation
um that an in-person visit you know
absolutely is required I don't think if
a person's in crisis and just because
there's a snowstorm that you can add a a
drug so I'm sorry did I misunderstand
your question well I'm just my my
question is really if the choice is
an in-person visit I mean a Telehealth
visit or no visit not necessarily a
crisis situation we're talking with this
this it's getting a prescription done so
the person is going to run out of their
medication they can't get for the to
their in-person visit
isn't the Telehealth better than
thank you I think I better understand
your question and you'll see in the the
amendment that I proposed is that a
refill of existing prescriptions
um would not require an in-person visit
so if it's you know that sort of routine
thing but I think we owe children to
protection if you're increasing dosage
decreasing dosages adding additional
drugs the drugs aren't working those
sort of things require an in-person
visit but yes some situations and that's
why I put that in there simple refill
you know shouldn't necessarily acquire
an in-person visit thank you
other questions
say no other questions thank you thank
you very much thank you all
hey also signed up to speak is James
Monahan from New Hampshire Community
Health Association
you said you only need two minutes
thank you Mr chairman my name is Jim
Monahan with the DuPont group and I'm
here today on behalf of the
um the community Behavioral Health
Association the state's 10 Community
Mental Health Centers
I can think
only take two minutes because I want to
focus mainly on two things I agree with
um with Matt hood that Senate Bill 500
does everything and more the 238 does
and should Senate Bill 500 be enacted
there's probably not a need for 238
um and thanks to the hard work of this
committee to address the issue in a more
comprehensive way rather than an issue
by issue way
um I am concerned as I'm sure the
committee is because you took the time
to change the effective date on 500 that
we're running up close to the deadlines
on on the public health emergency I
think there's a senator in the room so
I'll be careful but that that delay is
very much you know in somewhat in the
hands of the Senate to try to address
that now and so anything that this
committee can do to move that along I
think would be helpful
um you know Senate Bill 238 was proposed
to the Senate Health and Human Service
committee on February 15th uh that the
senate had the hearing they amended the
effective date and passed it on the same
day it was on a good cost to get taken
care of in a timely fashion but it did
get hung up in the Senate on some of the
issues associated with Senate Bill 253
which is crossed over I think that's now
in the possession of the children family
law committee that's probably a better
place to deal with a lot of these very
appropriate questions around parental
consent and access to records and so
it's been a little frustrating that this
bill and this topic has been hung up on
that you don't don't have any control of
that so
um I would hope that uh should you
proceed you're certainly going to take
into account that you that Senate Bill
500 addresses that we'll be working in
the Senate to try to get that bill
out of committee on the senate floor
to the house for concurrence and to the
governor all by May 11th which won't be
easy but we'll try very hard and we may
be back to ask for help on that so I'll
talk more about process than the bill
but if you have any questions on the
legislation I'm happy to do what I can
to answer them hey thank you any
questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you did you say
Senate Bill 253 I just wanted to make
sure I wrote that down I think I have
the number right um my computer's not
loading so people are not correct yes
and am I right it's in health children
and family law yeah thank you
other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
very much thank you
I have no one else signed up to speak
for Senate Bill 238 does anyone else
wish to testify on Senate Bill 238
seeing no one I am going to close this
public hearing on on this Senate Bill
38. uh that concludes our public
hearings for today uh we are going to be
going into executive session and
considering a number of other bills for
which we have already had public
hearings so thank you all
uh sure we'll we'll take a is five
minutes enough you want ten
all right we'll have a 10 minute recess
foreign
at this time and we we're going into an
executive session uh there were seven
bills noticed in the calendar for today
and I would like to proceed
um pretty much in the order that they're
listed uh first one would be on Senate
bill 50. relative to pharmaceutical drug
take back programs do I have a motion on
that bill
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman I move that we
vote ought to pass I put a motion for
ought to pass okay is there a second
representative Palmer seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative Cushman or
um sure
sorry just sitting down
this is the prescription buyback this is
enabling us to move away from putting
our
used medications or no longer prescribe
medications or medications left over
from patients who have been discharged
or died
in healthcare facilities like nursing
homes so we can stop using the yucky goo
that creates mold and it's a really
nasty way of getting rid of these meds
and this is just a nice clean way we can
give them back to the pharmacy
okay thank you any other discussion on
this motion
uh representative Merchant um thank you
recently the um
DEA has now required that pharmacies not
saying that to support the bill but just
to give people an update on what's
happening on controlled drugs anytime an
opiate is dispensed by your Pharmacy is
required to actually give the patient or
the caregiver something to dispose of
medication so it goes back into trying
to broaden the issue of
ability to dispose of controlled drugs
to keep them out of the supply chain
pick up the patients so I support it
thank you
any other discussion
okay seeing done I'll ask that the Clark
Hollow role
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative King I'm
guessing and sorry actually I'll go
first yes
[Laughter]
representative cofo
yes
representative McLean yes now you're up
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelozov yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay
absolutely
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative elderber elberger yes
representative Palmer yes representative
priests
yes
and representative McDonald yes
19.
and one not voting
if there's no objection I'd like to put
this on the consent calendar
okay moving on what's up
yeah
representative Cushman you'll be doing
the report on that
okay thank you
moving on to Senate Bill 83 do I have a
motion
representative pushman
uh yes I move that we uh ought to pass
SB 83
all right thank you
do I have a second
representative Shapiro seconds I'm sorry
um representative Cushman do you wish to
speak to your motion
yes thank you this bill is um pretty
common sense I think it's been a long
time coming
um just allows
the um aprns and certified nurse
midwives to sign in place of a physician
on anything that's within their scope of
practice and I hope you'll support the
ought to pass motion thank you thank you
any other discussion representative
Nagel I would just add that it basically
is bringing statute into reality because
for the most part this all already
exists so it's important that statute
meet reality
thank you of the discussion
so you know the discussion
the clerk is ready I'll ask how you call
the roll
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay no vote
representative Freitas
yes representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative elderberger yes Al Berger
I'm sorry
representative Palmer
yes
representative priests
and representative McDonald yes
19-0
okay again if there's no objection I'll
put that on the consent calendar
moving on to Senate Bill 34 relative to
the controlled drug prescription health
and safety program do I have a motion
I have an amendment
oh okay
foreign
does everyone have the amendment it's
almost all around it's working it's way
down that side
make a motion to approve the amendment
to move it you move uh Amendment one
three five two h
uh to pass I assume ought to pass thank
you is there a second
uh representative Leon seconds
representative Merchant would you like
to speak to your motion yes
the reason for the amendment is the fact
that
when we looked at the bill initially it
says the commission may authorize the
program
and I speaking to the Department of
Health Human Services my concern was
within the department
is accountability if you leave it open
to a program you really a program a
program cannot sign a document
a person can so at that point in time
we're talking about release of
information I want to be sure that there
was some traceability back to a person
who has the authority by granted to them
by the commissioner so something
inadvertently goes wrong we can go back
to that individual and saying You
released the authorization you had the
authorization to release the information
but you shouldn't have authorized it so
I wanted to be clear to the department
that we have traceability and
accountability
to an individual somebody that we can
trace to being authorized by the
commissioner
that was the only reason for making the
changes in the department I worked with
them in collaboration and they support
the amendment
great thank you another discussion on
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
the vote is the vote is going to be on
the amendment 2023 hyphen 1352h
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Copo yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative yes
representative Weber yes representative
McCain uh here uh represent friedas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative elberger yes
representative Palmer
yes representative priests yes
and representative McDonald oh yes
19-0
one not voting
hey do I have a motion on Senate bill
34. I'll make a motion to ought to pass
as amended
hey Senator representative Merchant
makes a motion on Senate Bill 34 ought
to pass is amended is there a second
representative Leon seconds
any discussion
seeing none I'll ask at the call the
wall if he's ready
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman she stepped out
representative Bill King yes
representative kofault yes
represent McLean yes
representative Seth King yes represent
Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay not here
uh representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
represent Merchant yes
representative elberger yes
representative Palmer yes representative
priest yes
representative McDonald yes
makes it 18-0
okay again if no objections we will
send that to the consent calendar
okay next up is Senate bill 236.
do I have a motion it is relative to
Health and Human Service
establishing a committee to study
non-profit organizations Contracting
with the Department of Health and Human
Services to Children's Services
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman um I move in expedient to
legislate
okay is there a second I'll second
representative McLean seconds
oh I'm sorry okay representative
Missouri
uh discussion no representative land do
you want to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you Mr chairman
um I I appreciate the motivation behind
this study committee however I I do have
some concerns about adding yet another
study committee when we're looking at
talking about insurance coverage which
is outside of the scope of this
committee I believe that this is
something that can adequately be dealt
with in discussions and ad hoc
committees and therefore this is
unnecessary
other representative Shapiro
um I hate to disagree with my colleague
having been on a couple of study
committees one of which was the study of
Aces
which I thought was so incredibly Broad
and brought so many people to testify
who were interested and um that this
that this particular issue that was
brought to us is so narrow that it
actually
at least given my experience is perfect
for a study committee because it's a
very narrow question that can bring
limited number of people together and
come out with a very concrete um
solution or recommendations for
Solutions
so
I agree that there's um you know the the
issue of there being a lot of committees
and difficulty appointing people to them
is an issue but I just thought that this
was kind of the perfect
um
this was the perfect committee
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman I agree with
representative Shapiro and I will just
add that um
these organizations of the organizations
that provide services to our most
vulnerable children
but if they cannot
find affordable insurance which was the
underlying problem they will either stop
being available and we already know we
have a shortage of people available to
do this kind of work or the price will
go up and we know who's paying the price
tag for that so on behalf of our
taxpayers and our children I'm I'm going
to vote against the itl representative
Nagel and then representative
um
I agree with everything you said
superficially when I saw this bill I
wrote why and huge letters on front of
it and I I um you know everything that
the good representative here and I have
ever done was all done on an ad hoc
basis and I think we got a lot of great
stuff done that way
the problem that the one gentleman that
testified was we tried to do it and they
wouldn't listen to us and that was the
only reason why the bill was brought
forward if he hadn't said that so if
there's an alternative way to you know
put a fire under people's backsides to
bring them together to discuss it I
agree with everything you just said but
he's saying that that's not the case so
I'm that's representative
when I read this bill I didn't quite get
it and when the gentleman who testified
said it wasn't about
ensuring the children it wasn't the
children's insurance it was all the
agencies that work with highly volatile
and
children that they're not able to get
insurances so you know Nashua children's
home I'm making that up I don't he
didn't list the organizations Waypoint
so if they can't get in insurance they
can't treat any of these children at any
of these children so the state of New
Hampshire would be way out of luck with
what to do with these children and so
the gentleman who testified I'm sorry I
can't remember his name he wanted the
weight of the legislature
to help with
figuring getting all the
what do we call them shareholders in
place so that we could have a serious
conversation and figure out a solution
to this so
um I I know we have too many study
committees and I'll volunteer to serve
on this one as I do with something that
I am passionate about this ultimately
comes into being and the speaker they
asked me to make a recommendation I'll
remember that I absolutely and you know
I've I've been stuck before so I've
served on the guys on either side of you
know that that does happen yes
representative Merchant although that
didn't work out sorry about that but
representative Lane I think maybe you
weren't here for that
um testimony
and it was compelling so I I'm I'm if I
could vote twice for this I would
representative Merchant
thank you
I've worked on several ad hoc committees
and I think the real
time things have worked through an ad
hoc committee is when all the
stakeholders are there because they want
to be there and they want to do
something and take some sort of action
what I heard
representative
talked about it they've tried that and
it's not working
so I'm not really a strong supporter
committees and commissions and so forth
we have enough to begin with but I think
sometimes
perhaps a Sparrow's Point of View this
is narrow it's very specific and I think
it's a way to bring the stakeholders
together
with the
power if you will of this body
about the importance of it to get
something accomplished because I think
ultimately it comes down to being able
to care for the children and if they
can't get the insurance we're going to
disrupt it so therefore I would vote
against the itl and vote ultimately to
pass it
representative Missouri and then
representative
um
I have in my notes um from that hearing
specifically a question was asked about
a committee Sunset date
that
um I don't believe there was ever or
we'd have never resolved that so if
anyone's heard anything about that
go ahead sure um thank you I actually
reached out to OLS earlier today and
because this is this is chapter law not
statutory law it automatically dissolves
after the report is filed so we don't
need to have a sunset provision on that
thank you thank you
okay uh representative Cushman thank you
Mr chairman
um I'm just going to support my
colleague
um our vice chair on her motion
um I think I I do feel for the
um organizations who are having trouble
with the insurance but I think that they
would do well to work directly with
Representatives who are willing
um to help them on some specific
legislation and if some stakeholders
um do not want to participate the ones
that they've been trying to participate
with
um who wouldn't entertain it then they
would miss out on the Drafting and the
crafting of that legislation and we
really need to reduce study committees
have already voted for several this term
and I typically have a rule that I I
don't want to create study committees um
so I will be voting against
representative Leon
uh thank you Mr chairman while I wasn't
here in person uh it was a very nice
break to watch our footage from our
hearings to interrupt why I was out of
town so I was able to watch and observe
one of the things that I found with my
limited but with my experience in the
house is that we have study committees
and they also can't compel anybody to
come and testify so while they do have a
little bit more weight of the
legislature they still rely on people's
cooperation and I've found that odd ad
hoc committees often end up coming in
with more buy-in than study committee
results as well so while I appreciate
that this could add some heft I know
that I've seen very very solid very
strong efforts come if I'm an ad hoc
basis and I I don't think
I I don't I don't I appreciate their
concerns and their challenges but I
don't know that this would actually
solve that problem
representative Weber
I will just
refer back to the history of this issue
and the fact that I think we have
somebody has put in a bill to address
this problem I think twice before
already
and sometimes it's a limited liability
Bill and sometimes it's an insurance
bill but the fact is that we have
tensions between
uh
the cost of insurance on the one hand
the desirability of the services that
are being provided
and some of the solutions which have
been to limit liability which then
leaves some people without a remedy so
the stakeholders are not just
DHHS and these care providers it also
involves things like The Trial Lawyers
Association and we people have been
working on this for some time now
without a result and so just saying that
we're going to do that again and hope it
works doesn't work for me which is why I
I but I share all the concerns that have
been expressed about study committees I
I do
truly believe that but I've also I think
this one is is one that's Worthy
representative Shapiro I just I just
want to make the point that I you know
in regards to this debate it's really
about
um whether a study committee process
would work or an ad hoc
um
get together would work and and uh I
just want to make it clear that I think
nobody's accusing the other side of this
debate of not caring about kids or not
caring about those agencies being able
to take care of kids and
um I think we're all on the same side
that this is an issue that would
that would be really important for us
all to solve both from you know a
financial point of view but also from
the point of view of taking giving kids
the best care
um so none of us know which way it will
get solved or if it'll get solved but I
think
um I'm going to vote against the itl but
representative Weber and I just had one
further uh point that I wanted to make
that hasn't been made before
um this also it's not a huge committee
it's not a huge commission it's two
members of the house and we already have
one person who said they wanted to work
on it and one member of the Senate so
it's it's not a huge use of legislative
resources thank you representative
profile did you end up I did thank you
Mr chairman so
um
having just started work on the
committee on commissions I am acutely
aware of
um whoops the number of study committees
and commissions that and this I think
this is at least the third rendition of
the committee on Commissions in the past
two decades so
um
you know I I guess my concern is
expanding the number of committees and
commissions in this case study committee
but also the effectiveness of that group
and the likelihood that that that the
recommendations coming back from that
group will be implemented there is an
alternative that I would like to just
put on the table for your consideration
which is that
it is within the purview my
understanding is that it is within the
purview of standing committees to
address these kinds of issues and
whether that be
sort of an ad hoc working group going
off and and sort of doing some leg work
or
formally or and then formally
undertaking work as a standing committee
or just starting it as the standing
committee you know bringing stakeholders
in to examine this more closely I in
terms of Effectiveness I do believe that
if we had that level of participation
which is to say this entire committee
participating in that process we would
stand a much higher chance of actually
implementing the recommendations coming
out of that committee that is this
committee so I I'm going to vote against
I'm going to vote in favor of the itl
motion but I wanted to offer that as an
alternative
representative Nagel I know I'm not
supposed to ask this question but what
did the Senate vote on this
I'll put it for it to have made here
made it here obviously I'm just curious
it was closer I don't know what the vote
was
when I was yes I was looking all the
bills up and they voted
ought to pass with an amendment by vote
of five nothing
that would be the committee you know
it's like can I get a clarification from
representative coalfault about what he's
suggesting I'm not sure I understand
what he's suggesting is an alternative
go ahead and what I'm suggesting is an
alternative is that this committee
take on the the work that is outlined in
the bill
and and and the the specifics of how
that looks could could vary it could be
that we meet as a committee
and invite stakeholders in
or it could be that we
delegate to a working group
in preparation for this committee
you know holding more formal hearings in
in a in in that context
representative Weber
and I would say I I have seen that
process work the question is what we're
trying to achieve here
uh having served on a previous iteration
of the committee on commissions or
committee on committees uh one of the
things we did was we made the rule that
chapter law will expire at the end of
the term that we're all sitting in so
this this is not going to proliferate
it's not going to hang around doing
nothing it's not going to be an ongoing
issue that's item number one number two
if you are concerned about the use of
the resources of this body
this uses three people
and
I have a hard time getting behind
the use of
20 people
when a smaller number could do the leg
work so I guess what I'm saying is I
would prefer to pass this study
committee but if it is not passed my
preference would be for the chair to
appoint a small ad hoc working group
which is then an official committee it
has to notice its hearings so it's not
just people who
self-select who they're talking to
obviously there's some stakeholders who
may choose not to come but then as
representative Leon says they don't get
included and and that's on them but
a small ad hoc committee would have to
do its work under the provisions of the
right to no law and therefore would have
anybody who has an interest would be
unnoticed and able to come I mean they
can come anyway but that way they know
about it so that would be my second
preference would be to have a very small
ad hoc committee that is named by the
chairman and therefore a subcommittee of
this committee okay thank you
representative Leon and then
representative Merchant and then
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman there's definitely been some
really good and important points here
I'm wondering if it would make sense for
us to retain this so that we can do that
ad hoc and by doing that and having it
based on our disposition at the end if
our ad hoc committee comes up with
something we could have a hearing on
that non-germaine amendment in order to
get that into the January session so
that we can if we can find progress on
this and if we can make something happen
with that ad hoc group we don't have to
wait as long this would actually
accelerate it beyond the time frame of
that study committee because it seems
like we all understand the need for this
and we just simply haven't been able to
get from A to Z yet and perhaps this
will give us that opportunity
representative Merchant thank you
so I'll be clear I understand this
correctly um representative Weber and
also representative Cobalt and Leon
so it wouldn't per se be an ad hoc it'd
be actually an official subcommittee of
this committee so if we retain the bill
and the chair elects to create a
subcommittee which then has to go
through public noticing in 91a we're
still in essence creating a legislative
body that's going to pull the
stakeholders together is that how I
understand it
yep
representative Weber
uh yeah so although we have actually
generally referred to those committees
as ad hoc committees which may be the
wrong term for it but I chaired one once
and I would say I think that this
actually makes
really good sense in in the sense that
we can get some people going I think the
one issue with the ad hoc committee is
that it might be very useful to have
somebody from Commerce on it and I'm not
sure we can do that but I suppose they
could have their arm twisted up behind
their backs or something I I would have
to ask the clerk if it can be an
intercommittee thing I know that you can
appoint some as as a subcommittee of
this committee but the speaker would
have to do that right away from another
committee I I'm I'm just not sure
whether we have the ability to do it
across committees or not and and
um
I think
I just don't know
so representative a merchant and then
representative nadarapam
I mean representative Shapiro
I I was really gonna say something
similar which is uh I I'm agreeable to
this solution it doesn't seem that
different
um but that we that this committee
doesn't necessarily have all the areas
of expertise that is called for to solve
this problem so I think
uh you know either voluntarily
participating or being officially
appointed to this subcommittee I think
we need people from
for more well-equipped to deal with
insurance issues
representative
I was just going to say we can always
invite someone from another committee
whether they're officially appointed or
not
can't we
representative Nagel
um
the reason I like ad hoc committees is
that um
we're all equals and I I think that has
a huge amount of value but the other
thing we do too is we reach out to
everybody to make sure they're there and
I think that if we're I like this
approach the best I think is a great
idea but my my big concern is that we
really need to make an effort to reach
out not to say here's a notice and hope
you come type thing because I know
I've seen some really bad legislation
passed because certain people don't show
up partially because they didn't know
about it or whatever but I think we do
need to make that effort and that's
my only concern
thank you
Steve
Mr chair can we move the question
uh we just found out that we cannot put
some from someone from Commerce on the
committee
um we've checked with the clerk's office
have to send that off so thank you thank
you Christina
other discussion
all right what's the Madam
representative Leon um I'd like to
withdraw my motion
um in order to make another one okay and
then there's the second withdrawn
um
representative Missouri do you withdraw
your second
oh yes okay representative Leon um I
would like to move that we retain
um Senate bill 236.
is there a second second
uh representative Merchant I believe
seconds yes okay
um I need further discussion on this
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call a
bowl
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay no vote uh
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes yes
representative elberger yes
representative Palmer yes
representative priest yes and
representative McDonald yes
19-0
okay
very good
no hey that's good
I I suspect if we had stayed with itl
there may have been a few
unfortunately that's not on the docket
today
all right moving on uh to Senate Bill 30
relative to membership of the New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities do I have a motion
I'd like to make a motion that we ought
to pass
this bill okay is there a second second
representative Weber seconds
representative King do you wish to speak
to your motion
yeah I'll be short it's this is
essentially a short bill that just um it
adds in uh it subtracts not more than
and adds in at least 21 members and if I
remember right representative Weber
calculated that they needed 22.5
um and it also removes the language of
uh vacancies shall be filled by the
unexp expired terms so this is pretty
straightforward Bill and um so I ask
that you uh vote out to pass
thank you
any other discussion
seeing none
and the clerk is ready I will ask him to
call the wall
motion is ought to pass on Senate bill
30.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative coppol yes
represent McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay no vote
representative Freitas
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative
oops representative elberger yes
representative Palmer yes
representative priests yes
and represent McDonald yes
19-0
one notebook
okay
yeah
if there's no objection we'll put that
in the consent calendar
next up is Senate Bill 32 relatively to
the opioid abatement trust fund do I
have a motion
I do it
am I allowed to do it yeah sure I make a
motion ought to pass okay representative
Nagel moves out to pass
second on representative Merchant
seconds
representative Mabel do you wish to
speak to your Merchant
um this is my commission uh committee
commission whatever it is Council
um so I've been on this very short
period of time but one of the reasons I
actually ran for office was to get on
this commission I think it has
an incredible amount of value but what
was really needed our last hearing which
I'm still having incontinence over
because I actually had to chair the
meeting which I'd never done before
um but they were very nice and we got
through it but what the point of the
meeting was was to bring together a lot
of relevant governmental organizations
together to solve a problem together and
that's partially what this bill does the
other thing is it just adds a lot of
information on how we can do that the
best we can there's going to be roughly
300 million dollars that needs to get
dispersed to important organizations
within the state and for us as a group
to do that by ourselves would be really
challenging
um the other thing that's really
important is getting this money out as
fast as possible and the way it's
structured right now that's not going to
happen so there's a lot of organizations
that need this money to do their their
job to facilitate everything we talked
about earlier today prevention treatment
harm reduction on and on and on there's
about 10 different
categories of things that we're going to
be looking at there's 17 actually in
statute right now so it's a start it's
not a finish but it's an important bill
and I would beg you to please vote
all right thank you
any other discussion representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and um this is
absolutely a very important bill the
discussion earlier today did raise one
question in my mind what is harm
reduction and should that be defined in
our statutes I'm wondering if people
would be amenable to just pausing this
until next week and seeing about
potentially adding a definition of harm
reduction because I don't want the
equivalent of sunscreen to be using up
valuable dollars that should be paying
for things like syringe exchange and um
and dory's programs and all of those
the answer yeah yeah representative
Daigle
um
it's unfortunate I didn't bring all of
our materials because
um in the governor's
um
information on their I'm sorry I'm
getting all my nomenclature mixed up as
to what's a task force and what's that
and the other thing but anyways there's
a a long description of what harm
reduction is and I have absolutely no
problem with tableing it and I can share
that with everybody here and you can see
what it says
um
representative Weber
I would also say that
oh I'm sorry I've got the wrong bill in
front of me I beg your pardon but
um I think
let me pull this one out
if there's somebody else who wants to
speak take them and I'll I'll look if
you want anyone else representative
Plaza
uh I I want to confirm what the previous
speakers uh said that I think it's an
important bill in right direction but uh
I think we need uh to take steps to make
sure that funds are appropriated
appropriately where they needed so I'm
not ready for to vote for it today but
so you would prefer to see it pushed off
till next week yeah yeah yes can I
respond to that
is that the pleasure of the body
seems to be well representative wanted
to respond representative Nagel I'm
sorry um
the process by which all these different
organizations are vetted is is
unbelievable and now that what this
would add actually is another level that
anything that we go we we approve has to
not only be approved by the opioid
abatement commission but it also needs
to go through the governor's commission
as well
um there's some of the smartest people
on the state working in these two
organizations and I I understand that
concern up to a point but that that
issue was raised right from the very
beginning when this commission was
started one of the reasons I wanted to
be on the commission is my people are
neglected and I wanted to be part of it
to make sure that they were included so
but I would be if you want I'd be happy
to share the information on how this
commission Works how it was created what
all the steps that it needs to go
through to have a program be approved
um you know where the money comes from
where it goes it's a totally separate
amount of money it's not coming out of
the general fund it's not coming out of
taxes it's coming out of basically
I don't know if they go a plate where to
call the money from you know lawsuits
from pharmaceutical companies and it
will be about 330 million dollars and
that money has got to go to somewhere in
a reasonable time frame
okay I mean would you be amenable if
that's what I'm fine with waiting a week
the more knowledge is power I mean I'll
be honest when I to get ready for our
last meeting I read through all this
stuff I was really amazed and I think
you should see it because it's germane
to everything we do here I mean it
wasn't just about drug abuse and things
like that it was about the mental health
the 10-year mental health plan it was
about the 10-year opioid plan it was
really impressive and I think if you all
saw it it'll help us do our job better
going forward because I think most of us
don't even know about these things
um so I don't think it's Unique to this
bill as to everything we do
representative Merchant then
representative Shapiro and then
representative Weber
thank you
I support this for several reasons a lot
of things that we've talked about it
does provide a clear guideline to how
the funds get distributed and dispersed
but also remember it's not just what the
legislative body wants to put on
constraints there is I'm sure within the
settlement agreements
constraints within those agreements and
how the funds can be utilized so
regardless of what this legislative body
wants to do the real constraint is going
to be what's in those contracts that
were signed between the parties and how
the funds can be utilized so therefore
I'm sure within those constraints
there's a limitation to what they can
and cannot be used for if you will so I
think trying to micromanage it at this
point in time Beyond what's already
there in those contracts which I'm sure
were fully vetted
um I don't think there's a reason to
hold that up
representative Shapiro
I I'm ready to vote for it now but I'm
I'm also okay with
um voting on it next week but I think we
have to clarify that if we're going to
do that it's because someone's going to
bring in a specific Amendment not that
we're just going to get more information
um
with a definition of harm reduction
which I think was
um
I think there were several of them given
earlier but I think we shouldn't have
too much trouble doing that thank you
representative Weber
thank you and thank you Ola for allowing
me the time to rummage through my papers
I do think that the issue of a
definition of harm reduction is very
relevant to the role we heard earlier
today but I don't think it's relevant to
this one
partially because of what we've heard
from everybody about the way everything
is set up but we need to also remember
that although it says that the
commission is going to award grants and
revolving loan funds and matching funds
It also says that all disbursements or
grants shall require approval of the
governor and executive Council so for
people who are rightly concerned about
uh
who is dispersing the funds and whether
they are duly elected and whether they
answer to the General Public
these all require two levels of
involvement already and given the
very extensive statutory scheme that
already exists
I would be hard put
to
um
vote for a specific definition of harm
reduction which I think then muddies the
waters rather than clarifying them
aside from whether I agree with the
actual definition that people come up
with which I think is going to be a
sticking point so I I have no objection
to putting it off for next week and
letting people try if that will make
people more comfortable but I'm
certainly in much more inclined to vote
for the bill as it is
thank you representative Nagel
um you actually
simultaneously gave the solution and the
problem
um we've had
um about I don't remember what dollar
figure number of Grants already approved
that are sitting in the executive
Council now waiting
to be approved so the the time so it's a
roadblock and it's and it's a solution
at the same time but it's important and
it is and it does exist so as far as
harm reduction if I can also say that I
mean I just got back from a meeting in
Dallas I mean we could have sat for
hours and days to talk about harm
reduction I don't think we're going to
come up with a solution to that Within
the next week what I I mean now that
we're creating new committees and ad hoc
committees and things like that I mean
at some level that's already being done
but at the same time it's something for
us to maybe think about because some of
these committees that testified before
us are already talking about those
things so I'm sure they have data
information about it but I I don't think
we're going to solve that issue in a
week
representative Cushman thank you um I
was just looking at at the bill and
it is possible that we could pass this
today and then I meant bring an
amendment to
um the bill we heard earlier today
because they're in the same section and
we could Define it there and it would
apply to both
okay
other discussion
because the question is do we want to
move forward we have a motion on the
floor right now we're about to pass do
we want to proceed with that motion or
representative Leon
um thank you I I just would feel I I
feel a little nervous about making it a
very large blank check I know it's
checked by the executive Council but I
have this gut feeling where I'm just not
comfortable with that if we can wait
till next week I can see what language
we're also doing then otherwise
personally I'm going to need to vote
against the ought to pass because I only
want to support legislation I feel very
comfortable supporting
um I I'd prefer to be able to vote for
it but I'll go with the will of the
committee
representative Weber
and I just want to make the point that
this is already a much larger Bill than
harm reduction I mean it's already a
much larger
fund and it then then harm reduction so
that trying to micromanage one small
piece of it with a definition
um
may make things considerably more
difficult rather than less
representative Nagel there's actually 17
different elements to this in statute
now
and that's only one of 17.
another representative Leon
um I guess it's a matter of whether it's
my no today or a possible yes tomorrow
I'll go with whatever all of you guys
would rather have me say
well again we have a motion on the floor
um
I guess Representative demago no in a
way it starts with you you'd have to
withdraw your motion
so you you want the vote to go forward
okay
all right so there's a motion on the
floor about to pass on Senate Bill 32
any other discussion
I'm seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the wall
representative Leon no
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative profile yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative peloso
no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay no vote
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative elberger yes
representative Palmer yes
representative priest yes
and representative McDonald yes
16-3
okay and Nova one Novo
all right The Minority Report okay sure
okay and obviously it'll go on the
regular calendar
okay and then the last bill for our
consideration uh today is uh Senate bill
35.
uh which is can I ask a question oh sure
uh the motion
representative Leon you would go with
retain maybe um I'd go what I I'll need
to draft the amendment but it not to
pass as amended okay
which one are you talking about I'm on
Senate on uh 32 the one where I'm
writing The Minority Report oh okay
okay uh so the LA again the last bill
this morning for our consideration and
executive session the Senate Bill 35
relative to RSV vaccine Administration
do I have a motion
representative pushman thank you Mr
chairman I have an amendment here I move
that we amend house uh Senate Bill 35
with Amendment
2023-1413h and you have copies of that
foreign
and representative lay on seconds the
emotion to about to pass on Amendment
1413h representative Cushman do you wish
to speak to your motion yes thank you
so as we expand authorization to
administer more and more vaccines
outside of medical settings first we
started with pharmacies
um optometrists soon possibly that's a
medical setting but it's not a
traditionally where you would expect to
receive a vaccine we need to ensure that
these other professionals that are that
we're bringing in to do this are doing
this safely and with proper training and
properly follow-up especially when we're
authorizing them to give vaccines that
are very new
um in 2021 rep Merchant and I uh worked
together on the language in RSA 318
colon 16b which is where
um SB 35 is making changes and we agreed
that if we were to authorize Pharmacy
professionals to administer vaccines
outside of medical settings there needed
to be some safeguards in place so we
required some technique on some training
on recognizing and Reporting adverse
reactions injection technique
um and we also included a requirement to
comply with RSA 141c colon 20f regarding
the vaccine registry
that's all well and good unfortunately
we found out during testimony on HB 1606
and 2022 that pharmacies were dropping
the ball on informing patients that they
had the right to opt out of the vaccine
registry and they were sweeping the
private medical information into that
government system without consent so
already we had some failure there on the
part of these on the part of the
implementation of this new authorization
for pharmacy professionals and I don't
mean any offense to Pharmacy
professionals but the laws are
especially federal laws they're written
strongly in favor and support of vaccine
manufacturers as I see it and off it
often results in harm to the Privacy
rights and even at times to the health
of patients and so it was good that HP
1606 passed and you know hopefully that
issue with the registry is is solved
however there Remains the issue of low
reporting of Adverse Events following
vaccination with this bill we're
authorizing Pharmacy professionals to
administer vaccines that aren't even on
the market yet they're very new it's
important for post-approval surveillance
of new vaccines to have good data so
safety signals can be caught early and
dealt with and and prevent further harm
and we do know we do that through the
Bears the vaccine adverse event
Reporting System it is not a perfect
system but it's the only one we have and
one of the things that makes it not so
perfect is That vaccine Adverse Events
are grossly underreported there are
analyzes finding that the true number of
reactions are 10 to 100 times higher
than we have in the system
even though medical professionals are
required by federal law and in our New
Hampshire statute Pharmacy
professionals are required to report
Adverse Events to theirs
um this amendment adds an enforcement
mechanism
basically we're authorizing you this
extra scope additional scope to your
practice and we expect that with that
there will be responsibility in
following through with the requirements
and if they can't be
upheld what's in statute then the
authorization to administer vaccines for
an individual who was authorized by the
statute will be revoked the Board of
Pharmacy already has the authority under
318 5A to accept complaints and revoke
this authorization but this makes it
clear that this is the consequence for
for not reporting those events and
there's a 60-day window
within 60 days they just have to make
that report if they after they become
aware of a patient experiencing an
adverse event and
um the they're very specific they're
listed and they they the farm receive
professionals should know all of this
information it's it's listed
um on theirs there's a table of
reportable events for every vaccine
and they're
um
and there are also vaccine manufacturer
contraindications these are all things
that you would expect someone
administering these would would be aware
of
um so they get that 60-day window to put
the report in because it can be timely
um and you know from what we see it's
pharmacists are not usually the ones who
do find that someone has had an adverse
reaction it's usually another
professional but while we have this here
if it is does take place and they are
aware of it and no no
um report has been submitted they then
have to submit it if they want to
continue to administer vaccinations
thank you and representative Merchant
I'll speak against it but I also want to
address some things first of all
I've enjoyed working with representative
Cushman on the vaccine Bill 1606 and
trying to address the concerns that were
raised
let me talk about some of the concerns I
see with this amendment one is the Board
of Pharmacy as she stated currently has
authority to discipline a pharmacist if
there's something that they don't do
that they should be doing
um that's where the appropriate
Authority resides to discipline the
professional back to the licensing board
number two it creates a double standard
why as why do pharmacists have this
requirement but Physicians don't Pas
don't nurse practitioners don't anyone
else out there who's given vaccines why
they don't have the same requirement
placed upon them I'll be willing to work
with representative Cushman to deal with
that issue more broadly and I'll talk
about narrowly
number three under the revocation
the way I read it right now it's
permanent there's no recourse you can't
say to somebody well you're going to
have your ability to immunize somebody
for 90 days is it because at this point
in time the way I read it it's permanent
there's no
um Authority by the board to reinstate
the license
number three or four Adverse Events many
times
don't occur at the time of
administration so you may have a patient
that comes into the pharmacy you
immunize the patient they sit there for
30 minutes whatever time you think so
a lot of Adverse Events are not
immediate they happen
three four maybe a day or two later
they're not going to be there at the
pharmacy so how is the pharmacist going
to know that the adverse event happened
if they're not actually the one
observing it and most of the time if a
patient has an adverse event
I would say they're going to call their
Primary Care doc they're going to call
somebody in the medical team
not go back to the pharmacy so for all
those reasons I think the intent of this
is well intended but because of the
things I talked about discipline is
already there by the water Pharmacy
somebody can call the board make a
complaint
happens all the time
it creates a double standard we have a
stand for pharmacists but we don't apply
the same standard to other Healthcare
professionals
three there's no way to undo the
replication it's permanent the way I
read it now and four many Adverse Events
that you want to be reported don't
happen at the time they're in the
pharmacy they're having subsequently and
therefore the pharmacist would not know
about it but they're now required to
report something that they would not be
aware of
therefore I can't support the amendment
representative Shapiro
sure representative of Cushman
sorry
um so it says that they have to be aware
of it so it's once they become aware of
it and as long as a report hasn't
already been filed
um so if they aren't aware of something
there's no way that they can report it
if if it goes to another Medical
Professional then then that medical
professional should be the one to report
it
um but if you're having a conversation
with your pharmacist and you say you
know last month after my flu shot you
know I've had this lump on my on my arm
that just won't go away
um and the pharmacist doesn't report
that then I think that would be an
instance that this bill is here for
um if they and if they the pharmacist
would then ask you know have did you
file a bear's report or did anyone and
if they find out that none has been
filed then it it should fall upon them
to file it because they are the first
point of contact and especially if after
they were the ones who administered it
um the board does have the authority
um to discipline and but it is permanent
for a reason because this is an extra
authorization that we gave
um and I think that it the consequence
needs to be serious because these
reactions are very serious people die
from vaccine reactions people become
sick for life and
um I think the laws are are largely
written in favor of protecting vaccine
manufacturers and if if pharmacies are
very fast-paced and
I think that it's easy
um
for things to slip through the cracks
and we need to really send the message
that this is very important and it's a
requirement if you are going to be
authorized to administer them they won't
necessarily have any action taken
against their license it's just this
additional authorization that we've
given these professionals
they just it that individual won't be
able to do it anymore so that was
deliberate
um and the as far as a double standard
these rules the
under 318 16 B that we worked on I mean
we we set these up and they're not in
place for the other professions
um and that is and it was a double
standard then and we worked on that
together and
um the reason is because this is a new
area
um
where these professionals have a new
um scope added to or a new authorization
added to their scope of practice and I
think it's important because they may
not always be in this situation where
they're used to follow doing this kind
of surveillance so it needs to be here
um and I would like to see it you know
add it to other professions too if this
is a problem across the board let's deal
with it we have this in front of us now
we want to add more vaccines to
authorize them to do these vaccines fine
but let's just put the the Safeguard in
place
representative Shapiro
thank you I share some of the concerns
that representative Merchant has but
um on the other I also have
um considerable amount of
um
thinking about that this is a problem
that should be addressed and I have a
confession to make that I had the
coveted vaccine and I had an adverse
reaction and
nobody said anything about reporting it
um
so that was a little bit confusing to me
eventually I reported it
um
one of my questions about the specifics
of this amendment is that
the last sentence where it says failure
where it talks about the consequence for
not submitting a report
who would actually have
who's whose authority to provide these
vaccines would be revoked would it be
the pharmacy would it be the pharmacy
tech who gave the would it be the person
or would it be the organization
it would be the person it's a it says
anyone authorized to administer under
the section in the section authorizes
Pharmacy pharmacists Pharmacy interns
and lysis
Pharmacy assistance sorry I'm pharmacy
technicians and who would have the
jurisdiction to to make that decision to
keep track of it the Board of Pharmacy
under
um the parent section
um it's 318 colon 5 Dash a is where they
have
um the ability to make rules and
apply disciplinary action
representative King
uh thank you chairman
um
my question is for representative
Merchant
um if you were hypothetically a a
pharmacist and you administered a
vaccine and I think you're right 99 of
the time it's going to be right then and
there but if you did see somebody
experience an adverse reaction why
wouldn't you report it to Bears is there
is there some financial burden or time
burden that would make it prohibitive or
I just don't understand thank you
no it I would say if you are with a
patient and say the patient came from a
physician's office and it was
um three or four hours after the visit
and you talk to the patient the patient
says they think you can have an adverse
event you should be at that point in
time reporting it because you're the one
aware of it the question at that point
in time is that as the pharmacist is
dealing with the patient you're
encountered with them
if they're hearing from the patient
about a concern
and that concern elevates it to a point
of being an adverse event to a vaccine
they should be reporting it
it doesn't always have to be the vaccine
that you gave it could be a vaccine
someone else gave you become an aware of
it so under the
board if you are become aware of any
adverse event to a vaccine regardless if
you gave it or not you should be the one
reporting and helping the patients
report it
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and this kind of if I
I understand
um representative Merchants
administrative concerns uh with the
amendment and and I I share those
concerns
um you know but I I do think that
as we do these things there has to be
some teeth somewhere I myself personally
was very frustrated trying to opt out of
the registry and if indeed we do have a
chronic amount of Under reporting with
respect to theirs
um I guess maybe you know the answer
just maybe you don't are you aware are
there any current consequences
um at all with respect to reporting or
what are they if they if they do exist
the consequence would be with Board of
Pharmacy if someone is doing some the
Federal Law requires it and if you're
not following the federal law or
following the state law the Board of
Pharmacy has under jurisdiction
can at that point in time discipline the
pharmacist for doing something they
should have done so the appropriate
place to bring this is before the Board
of Pharmacy like any other professional
board because of doing something that
the law federal estate requires them to
accomplish a quick follow-up follow-up
yeah and and I'm just trying to learn
are you aware or anybody from in this
Committee of with respect to the
registry or with respect to Bears of any
activity in this regard any hearings
before the pharmacy board or the medical
board
um is this actively happening or is it
just a check box
it um
I haven't been on the board now for
about three years but I can share with
you my 10 years on the board this will
come into what they call non-public
hearing
so therefore the board would listen to
the testimony
during a non-public hearing at that
point in time if it gets to a point of
discipline then the discipline would go
into a public hearing but many times a
lot of the things are discussed because
we're trying to protect the professional
until some ruling occurs so a lot of
times we hear things in the board in a
non-public manner
in order to protect both the patient as
well as the practitioner until the board
ultimately makes a decision so
many times we've had things coming to
the board
and we act on it in non-public but we
came out of public and act on it in
public as far as the actual discipline
no I don't I don't know because I
haven't been on the board for three
years since that point in time but I
could do some research I don't know of
anything it's been a problem
um I do know at this point in time
there's been some concern by the medical
community about not getting reports over
to the primary care doc but that goes
back to the same thing sometimes the
patients don't want to report it
because the statute says only report it
if the patient wants you to
representative Palmer
it was sort of in in the line of this
because I'm definitely concerned about
somebody losing their you know
for one error losing their authorization
to administer vaccines
um and particularly depending on the
severity there's no there's nothing here
about severity so I pretty much always
have a low-grade fever after I get a flu
shot but I don't that doesn't get
reported
um I guess I would be much more
comfortable if this said something like
UH 60 days of becoming aware of
anniversary adverse event
in a patient result that that the Board
of Pharmacy would be notified
so that you put it back to the Board of
Pharmacy who has the authority to to
um
meet whatever Justice is required by the
the offense
representative Weber
I
my mine is a also a question to the
licensed Professionals in the room who
might be subject to this uh it seems to
me that we're all agreed that the
difference with the pharmacist from a
primary care provider or or other who
might have administered the uh an
injection and of course if we put this
in here it will reply to all injections
not just the um not just the the new one
um is
going back to what you were saying about
if you get an injection from your
primary care provider and suddenly your
arms turning red and looking icky you
you go back and say Hey you know I think
that vaccine was a problem
what do I do about this but you're going
to do that with your primary care
provider you're not going to go back to
the pharmacist and say that and I guess
one of the things I'm
worried about is we have the becoming
aware of language and so you're at your
kids little league game and somebody you
saw a week ago comes up to you and says
hey uh you know you gave me that jab
last week and uh
you know my arm doesn't look so good and
you say well you know I think you should
check that out with your primary care
provider that was the first thing I'd do
uh but then your kid gets hit with a
fastball and you're dealing with taking
the kid off this is tenuous I understand
but
uh there are reasons that you might it
might slip your mind under those
conditions that you were actually told
about an adverse reaction and your
um licenses now on the line and and I
think it also goes back to the
fundamental fairness issue but it if
this is already required by federal
statutes
then it seems to me that adding it
piecemeal into our statutes doesn't make
sense if what you want is for this to
happen it ought to be a standalone bill
that then tracks the federal statute in
our law but if it's already in the
federal statute it doesn't need to be in
our law so that's my thought
representative Merchant then
representative Cushman he represent
whatever raise a good point when you
talk about replication as permanent
in
Pharmacy today
if you cannot immunize a patient
you don't have a job
so you're not talking about this point
in time of just losing the possibility
of a license but losing a possibility of
a livelihood so
it's something not to take lightly I
don't think we should be ignoring the
reporting requirements but when you talk
about something that's horrific
revoked with no termination to it
the consequence to the professional is
dire
we're talking about that point in time
is not just losing the ability to
immunize but if you can't immunize you
probably won't be employed by a pharmacy
Walgreens and so forth because they
require you to have that certification
in order to be employed there so I just
want to stress to you folks the gravity
of this situation is extremely high
and at the same time
when you're looking at the likelihood of
it happening or people losing track of
it to what is the Weber's point of view
it can happen in that one simple thing
means all of a sudden your ability to
provide for your family and so forth is
totally off the table and I think that's
one of my concerns when you talk about
this whole thing the gravity of it's
huge
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I understand the concern there but
it's not true that if you can't
administer vaccinations that you
wouldn't have a job as a pharmacy tech I
mean there are other
um pharmacies that are not public facing
that do not administer vaccines they
deliver to nursing homes they deliver to
assisted livings
um there are mail-in mail order
pharmacies there are IV pharmacies there
are pharmacies and hospitals and other
medical facilities I mean there is a
wide range of Pharmacy
positions and they don't all administer
vaccinations
um and as far as the um the scenario
that representative Weber posited I
first of all it's highly unlikely but
um it's within 60 days I mean you have
60 days after hearing about it that's
two months to file the report and
I think it's I think it's a it's a long
enough period of time to give for
someone to do that and I really don't
think that there's any excuse not to do
it as a medical professional anyway you
know
um and this is a privilege that we have
awarded
um the pharmacists to to administer
these medical interventions and we need
to ensure that they are doing it safely
and if there's no reason that they
wouldn't
um not that they would not file Affairs
report then this is just a heavy warning
if this is if this isn't happening and
and they're they're doing their due
diligence and following through with the
care
then then there's no consequence to fear
but I think that if they're not that
they shouldn't be administering vaccines
I would also remind people that
you're absolutely right representative
Cushman the technicians can give
vaccines but the
reporting requirement falls on the farm
assist not the pharmacy technician so if
pharmacy technician was to give a
vaccine under the supervision of a
pharmacist and the pharmacist is busy
they justify that the patient qualifies
for the vaccine they have a technician
who's been trained to give the vaccine
technician gives the vaccine and doesn't
tell the pharmacist about an adverse
event
it's not the technician who's going to
be held accountable it's the pharmacist
because they're the ones that have three
requirement to report it
representative Cushman I mean
representative Leon and then
representative alberger
um thank you Mr chairman
um I think this is touching on one of
the critical things that our current
regulatory structure relies on
post-market surveillance is critical in
order to ensure the ongoing safety of
any product that's approved by the FDA
um I I haven't dug into the the
specifications of the trials around the
RSB vaccine but I do know that the covet
vaccine was significantly handicapped by
the fact that the
um the crossover allowed basically made
it so that you couldn't evaluate any
long-term effects so that left that one
vaccine to evaluate based on post-market
surveillance through vares and other
Associated ways to catch Adverse Events
in the community now I'm biased to
what's happened in my career we had we
had the cardiovascular stents the drug
eluding stents they were great until
they started flaking off and they
started killing people with blood clots
because they were only anticoagulating
for a certain amount of time because
people were keeping track of these
events and because there were some
Pathologists who were really digging
into it they were able to determine what
happened but that doesn't always happen
there's vaccines then have nebulous
Adverse Events and you end up looking at
a very large sample and with that large
sample you need to catch events in that
I would actually argue that those
low-grade fevers are exactly the sort of
thing that should be in there because
you're looking at the whole universe of
those Adverse Events and then you would
know that those are events where all you
had was the low grade fever and you
didn't develop other complications from
that vaccination without data we can't
make decisions and I think that it is
absolutely critical that not just with
pharmacists but if we follow up in the
future to have everybody else who's
unable to provide immunizations also
have to report to theirs I think that
that is absolute critical in order to
have a good quality of data because
right now those data are limited by the
fact that only some some events are
reported we're better off with with a
larger pool of data than we are with one
that is um
one that's truncated so um while I I
appreciate that maybe there could be
something about becoming aware in their
professional capacity of an adverse
event so that you're not hearing it on
the ball field or in passing I think
that it's absolutely important that
that we have our Pharmacists and our
pharmacy techs as a first line of
defense to catch any late events and to
catch these ones that are not otherwise
captured representative alberger
thank you Mr chairman my guess based on
basically no information except my own
experience is that the greatest loss of
information about adverse reactions
comes from the fact that we as patients
don't report them
I've had minor aches and and pains from
covid reaction worse from flu and even
worse from shingles and I never reported
them to anybody my guess is that that's
true more often than not unless somebody
is extraordinarily ill
um so trying to in some way hold a
provider
responsible for not getting information
in
leads the
provider at at a distinctly unfair
in a distinctly unfair situation and the
other comment that I wanted to offer is
if the reporting requirements already
exist with federal law that have
punishments attached then setting
another piece of legislation up here in
New Hampshire
is the Department of redundancy
Department
um
we had a conversation a little while ago
about there are too many committees
and this in a different way seems to me
very similar thank you representative
Palmer and then representative King and
then representative Kushner so I just to
clarify my position is I have no issue
at all with getting data and Reporting
and I agree with you that in the past
we've not done well with post marketing
um uh issues that have come up I think
that here this the last sentence is that
the punishment does not fit the crime
it's too severe and that and and if if
it if the remedy already exists in
federal law then great if the federal
law isn't strong enough
you know something a little bit less
than you know you're out one strike and
you're out we we need something a little
bit less so I'd like to see maybe a
little compromise representative King
and then representative Bushman I see
both sides of this
um debate
um I agree with both sides
um my question is mainly directed
towards Representatives Cushman and
Merchant a possible
a possible
um
agreement could be made if we just
change one word I'm thinking instead of
shall that could be May
so if so for example
um
instead of shallots like one strike
you're out you're gone and maybe it was
just something as small as I got a bump
on my arm and and I didn't report it you
know the pharmacist didn't report it and
Allison they've lost that seems pretty
brutal I get that on the other hand
not having any teeth also seems like a
recipe for unreporting whereas if we
change shell to May that would sort of
put the ball in the court of whoever's
making the decision and it'd be like hey
look if if this was such an egregious
um you know um event that it should have
been really should have been reported of
errors and wasn't then I could see there
being a revocation there but if it's
something small
I don't know just a thought
representative Cushman so I can clear up
there's a little confusion on what needs
to be reported and what doesn't so
um undervares there are there are
adverse effects that are considered
um that you you should report but
they're not legally required to be
reported such as a low-grade fever
um any new health condition temporarily
associated with vaccination but what
I've put here is I limited it to what's
legally required under the federal law
which does not have any penalty at all
there is no enforcement of this anywhere
um and so I I limited it to what is
legally required and they are very
specific there are tables on the HHS
website on the Veris website of
reportable events these are things like
yien Barre Syndrome
um intussusception after a rotavirus
vaccine
um and Guillain-Barre is a paralysis
paralyzing condition
um you know
cardiomyopathy or
um uh cardio
my myocarditis thank you after coveted
vaccine that's listed in the table for
reportable events for that so these are
very specific and they're usually pretty
severe
um so it's it's not every little issue
is going to be reported to Bears these
are things that there really is no
excuse for not reporting
um
to your question about the Shell versus
May
um
uh if if I had my colleagues support on
that I'd I'd be okay with
um you know bringing an amendment to say
may instead next week but if not then
um I I would like to push forward with
this because
um I think something just needs to be in
the statute and uh we have no penalty I
don't think that it's a crazy penalty
it's you either administer them and and
take all the responsibility with that
authorization to administer them or you
don't administer them
um with the 60 days and I mean even
having the revocation happen would
require that the patient goes to the
board and files a complaint and it has
to be one of these more egregious
adverse reactions and you know you would
you went 60 days without doing it I
think that that's a pretty
um
you know High bar to or it's a low bar
you know to set for these farm for
anyone administering something like this
so
I hope that clears some things up
representative Weber
having listened to the debate here as
always in this committee I've learned a
great deal
um uh and much of which I agree with and
and you know then we all come to
different conclusions but that's okay uh
I would like to just put forward a
process argument or a procedural
argument and and a conceptual argument
which is
rather than add this into one place with
one profession
and without
feedback from the general public
um
wouldn't it be a better way to proceed
if if what we're concerned about is the
federal statute doesn't go far enough
and doesn't have
the sort of teeth that we might want to
see
wouldn't it be better to put in a new
clean bill
uh requiring this either with the shells
or with the maze uh for all professions
and let that get a vote up or down so
that what we're doing is
alerting everybody who administers these
things in New Hampshire
reminding them of their obligations
rather than putting it on one small
section and then having that robust
debate about the shells in Maize because
I would be more comfortable with May if
we're talking about the shell online 12
as opposed to the shells on line 11
but if
you just make it say may then you've
taken all the teeth back out again and
if teeth is what you want then you need
shell rather than May
so my suggestion would be that we pass
um
that we vote on well we can vote on the
amendment obviously but my preference
would be just to vote on SB 35 up or
down and then decide
um have a clean bill about the mayor's
reporting that is consistent has been
checked clearly against the federal
statute so that we can all satisfy
ourselves about that and then sets a
policy that's the policy we want for New
Hampshire and have it be set for
everybody so you're basically
recommending would draw the amendment
and vote itl on the bill is that what
you're talking about no I'm recommending
uh I'm going to vote no on the amendment
and and I'm not going to vote for an IDL
I'm going to vote for not to pass oh
okay
but that's that's a whole other question
that we haven't gotten to yet okay
uh representative Shapiro
is something I don't know about but I
feel like I've heard contradictory
points of view about whether there's any
consequences for not making a report
um I've heard that there's no teeth the
federal law does not have any specific
consequences but I've heard also that
the licensing boards
require that people follow federal law
and so that would be the place now
whether it happens or not is a whole
different question but but that would be
the logical place and the actual place
where someone could take a complaint
saying I had an adverse reaction it was
never reported and the licensing board
would have jurisdiction
to take some action on that with a
physician or a
pharmacy tech or a pharmacist or whoever
um
that's correct basically any licensing
board I mean all professionals are
required to follow federal and state law
that's under their jurisdiction if
you're not following the federal estate
law and it's reported to the appropriate
licensing board whatever that board is
then it's up to the board at that point
in time to take appropriate action
against the individual
representative McLean
thank you so representative Merchant so
even if the federal law does not have
teeth in it the fact that somebody would
be going before the board for not
complying with the federal law they
could still lose their licensure related
to that yes and it's not just true with
vaccines it's true a lot of federal laws
if you look at things to do with
controlled substance for instance and if
you're as a pharmacist dispensing
something that you shouldn't have
dispensed there's nothing in the federal
law that's going to come after you it's
going to come down to the State Board of
Pharmacy because they're the ones that
control your license so anytime at least
in Pharmacy I can speak to have been on
the board if there is a licensed
individual out there
who is not following the appropriate
federal state law
then the Board of Pharmacy under
jurisdiction has the ability to
discipline the individual up to the
point of taking the license away
follow up
thank you Mr chair so I think you know
having listened to some really awesome
discussion I'm kind of at a place where
just looking at the administrative
consequences of the amendment I I
probably wouldn't want to support this
particular Amendment but I think that
representative Cushman is bringing up
you know some very valid concerns
um I think at the heart of it is in the
fact that theirs is not being complied
with and there has to be some teeth
somewhere and more so I think as we
become more fragmented I know when I was
a kid my doctor gave me every vaccine
and as it becomes more and more
fragmented there has to be we have to
find a way to get some structure because
maybe it's because people aren't
notifying on their own or maybe it's
just because the person who's
administrating never has that
opportunity to follow up
um so I think you know we need to look
at that but maybe not this amendment at
this time representative balazov uh
thank you Mr chair uh I still think this
amendment is a good thing as a written
uh the underlying bill has some uh very
concerning uh effects with bringing uh
um a civilization for uh in certain
context for this new vaccine and we
received online testimony at the
guardian a severe reactions to RSV
vaccines that can include paralyzing
effects
and
if somebody
repeatedly to because it's probably a
little bit Advanced that somebody is not
reporting uh those severe effects for
example for some batch of this uh of
That vaccine so
permanent suspension just for one person
who doesn't teleport it I don't think
it's too much because as was said like
some other jobs that pharmacy tech could
be doing
it's a unfair situation for provided but
we need to think about clients as well
and like there was some scenario about
like small bumper but for example if we
took at a wireless database
2038 to 120 report
a client had severe nausea and vomiting
from five minutes post injections and
for the next eight to ten hours so if
something happens in five minutes
there's a good chance that a pharmacists
would have seen it but instead it was
not reported so time came and that
patient was administered second dose
which caused uh
and vomiting for five minutes uh post
vaccination 100 degree fever severe
stomachache no bowel movements since the
day before vaccination for three days in
total and ultimately that client died so
I would say if the first reaction would
be reported that client would be saved
and maybe other clients would be saved
so yeah yes it's harsh for providers but
I think we need it for clients thank you
representative King you had your hand up
are you all set
okay any other debate any other
representative Weber
I just wanted to clarify I don't think
you don't research Theirs to see if a
specific person has had a reaction so
that's not the purpose of theirs it's to
collect a broad spectrum of public
health information so that we know
that whole range of possible effects so
that but it's not intended to be a a
protection for an individual I just
wanted to make sure that we were clear
on that
representative Merchant I would say to
this committee it's a lot of good
discussion going on
and touched upon some really important
things
if we're really concerned to
representative palazzo's concern about
the patient and getting down to that
level one of the things for us to
consider is that not only do we put the
information into the Bears program but
put it in the vaccine registration
because that's where most people are
going to go look for it so the point is
I would say that information should go
into vaccine registry
so that when the pharmacist is giving
the subsequent one
that information is in that vaccine
registry which is what I need
intervage doesn't help me so I go back
and say the same thing is that we
probably should be thinking about this
in a broader sense in having the
information prevares go into the vaccine
registry and all professionals report it
in that Arena so therefore we all have
access to it to protect the patient
because ultimately at the end of the day
that's what we're trying to do but if we
don't have access to the information we
can't do that so I would go back and
saying let's talk about a bill
subsequent to this that all
professionals who give vaccines
have the requirement to put it in the
vaccine registry so that everyone can
benefit from it as well as the patient
ultimately
now the discussion
representative Cushman
um it is part of what goes into the
vaccine registry to report adverse
vaccination events not necessarily that
you filed a varus report but there is a
place for that too already
does it say what is the event
no I don't know what it is it just says
you had an event doesn't tell what the
event was it was my mild fever and so
forth but I think that's where we should
focus our attention on is getting as
much information into the registry as
possible so that we can be as conclusive
to help the professionals out who are
helping the patient ultimately to
prevent
dire situations so the patient
representative Cushman representative
Nagel do you have your hand up
your glasses or okay go ahead I'm sorry
oh yeah are you really want to hear what
I'm saying don't you so I I think it's
an incredibly important discussion and
it's so important that I don't feel
comfortable to make a decision on this
right now I I think that um
that we need to vote on it yeah but I
really think that this warrants a bunch
of people coming together talking about
it working out the pros and cons an ad
hoc committee another Committee of two
I mean I'm actually proposing that I
think it's a great idea and I I think
that this is incredibly important
discussion with far-reaching
consequences and I just find it
entertaining that this started out with
a relatively very simple I hate to use
words simple or common sense because
those don't mean anything to me but um
bill but I think you started a great
discussion that really needs to keep
going and there are parts of this
amendment that I really don't like
specifically the penalty part I think
that needs a lot of work
um I agree that there needs to be
consequences but I think they've gone
too far
um but the but your idea is awesome it's
amazing and it warrants a committee of
at least 27 people representative
I usually don't have trouble making a
decision on something I read it and go
and this one frightens me I mean I agree
with everything you said about how
important it is
um that adverse reactions be uh reported
where they can be accessed and I I
admire you for bringing this forward I
just I I'm really I'm thinking about
like leaving the room so I don't have to
vote on this
um but I would like an ad hoc or further
study and I'd like to just pass the bill
but
um I'd be you know willing to again
um what work on an ad hoc committee to
to bring up reporting
um during last year the year before I
got to watch 400 people receive vaccines
in a facility that I worked at a
non-medical and one had an adverse
reaction which you know we had a
15-minute waiting area and then somebody
nudged me and said that fella over there
looks like he's passed out he's
incoherent and he's sweating and so we
got the nurse staff to go so you know
they do happen
um so
I don't I don't know but I mean I passed
it off to the medical professionals
right you know because I can't have him
draw his symptoms away
um not those symptoms I'm an art
therapist anyway
um so
I I'd like to vote down your Amendment
but hope that we do indeed uh
go forward with some kind of a committee
and that it applies to all professions
that are giving out and especially as
we're hearing that other bill in the
future about another group of medical
people that want to give out vaccines we
need accountability
sorry I went on a bit long but
representative Shapiro
I just want to say that I think if we if
there are further discussions they
should really be dual discussions about
um where information about the adverse
reaction can go that um could be seen by
Future
um
um clinicians or who has ever given
future shots but also that that somehow
reporting to theirs is encouraged
because
um
you know like I said my experience was
that
it was kind of ho-hum you know like
I I didn't get the impression at least
from my very limited experience that
everyone was making those reports
another discussion
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
I just want to say looking at the
significant list of co-sponsors on this
thing
um you know I I have enormous uh respect
for that and also for the intention
behind this thing but I do think that
the amendment does need more input
before it can go ahead and so like I
said in spite of all the respect I have
for the co-sponsors I just can't support
it at this time
representative alberger thank you Mr
chair and given that I'm not a member of
the committee I do hope that if some
group is formed to discuss this that it
be very clear that if someone like me as
a patient chooses not to report uh any
kind of adverse reaction that nobody uh
whether a pharmacist or a nurse or a
doctor gets held responsible for my
decision to not report
representative Nagel I just wanted to
make one more point that maybe a little
bit more General than specific but it
does it's germane to this so a couple
years ago I was involved in the
development of a thing called the
national pain strategy so we went met in
Washington to develop this thing and
there were 200 people in the room
sitting around talking about this and
they started bringing up points that
were totally inappropriate for clinical
practice and so I finally raised my guns
questioned my hand and I asked how many
of you guys are actually clinical
doctors not one person in the room
except me was a clinical doctor and then
I proceeded to tell them why this won't
work
one of my big concerns about this that I
think needs to be worked on is I'm not
convinced it's enforceable so um like
you know you say you told blah blah blah
I had it well there's no record of that
so how do you enforce it and then my
other big concern from having dealt with
the medical board
sometimes the medical board makes good
decisions and sometimes they don't and a
lot of it's the characters that are on
the medical board or the I'm sure the
Board of Pharmacy when Gary was there
was always I'm sorry representative
Merchant was always perfect but the
enforce ability was a concern to me also
um but I just it needs to get worked on
and it needs to have the voice of
clinicians involved in developing it
um otherwise it won't be enforceable
any other discussion
I think we've pretty well discussed it
pretty thoroughly
all right
um since we're ready to vote
I'll ask the clerk to call the wall
a vote is on Amendment
um one four one three h to Senate bill
35.
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King
yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel no
representative yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay
uh not here I'm sorry uh representative
Freitas no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
Representative elberger no
representative Palmer no
representative priests no
and representative McDonald I know how
representative felt I I too wish I could
leave the boom that's not an option
right
uh no
that is 7 4 and 12 against
one no vote
so it fails seven to twelve fails
okay do I have a motion on Senate bill
35.
motion to at the pass
motion's been made by representative
Merchant seconded by representative
Weber
uh any other discussion that hasn't
already been held representative
uh I will be voting uh against as I said
there's
some campaign testimony about paralyzing
effects from these vaccines and it's
being new it's not sufficiently uh
investigated we know that at least one
of the uh Pride uses uh has a long
history of not
properly reporting side effects on a
timely manner so it's a big concern for
me and second I don't know how many
constituents contacted you saying that
they wanted but
like
I had contacts from people who want to
administer it but I haven't heard like
about any emergency when we need to
hurry up and have this vaccine so for
this reasons I think we need to move
cautiously and I will be voting against
this time
thank you any other discussion the
representative Weber
well I just I just kind of wanted to
um
address some of the concerns expressed
by representative palazzov and I think
that he he makes very good points about
this is this is new we don't know a lot
about it
but on the other hand if if we believe
in personal choice and as we saw with
the covet vaccines there were people who
were very skeptical of them and rightly
so there were people who wanted them
very much and wanted them right away and
uh
just allowing it to be administered in
this fashion is a convenience for people
who want it but it doesn't
compel anybody who has any reservation
whatsoever
to Avail themselves of it so I see it as
as being something that's offered as a
service to our constituents and none of
our constituents have to actually do it
if they don't want to do it so I will be
voting in favor of the ought to pass but
I I do understand the concerns about
you know
how much do we know and do people want
this or not but those who don't want it
have the option not to have it
other representative of a cop
yes thank you Mr chairman so I will be
voting uh in favor of the ought to pass
motion I see this as a uh a question of
um well I'll call it deregulation which
is to say
um if if a uh if an adult has given
consent that they want to receive the
vaccine we ought to have a least
restrictive approach to
um to allowing people to administer That
vaccine in a way that is
as safe as it would be if it were
administered by anyone who is permitted
to do so today I will also point out
that the the statute already
permits the administration of a a wide
range of vaccines this one simply adds
RSV to that list so I will be voting uh
in favor of this
another discussion
representative Cushman
thank you I'll be really quick
um I Echo everything that representative
Koval says I will be voting in favor of
this and
um I just wanna
um kind of condition that or not
condition it but I'm doing it with the
um hope and the Assurance for my
colleagues that we will work on
something together
um to resolve this various issue going
forward so we can make sure that as we
keep adding more of these products to
the list that will make sure that
they're followed up on thank you
thank you another discussion of
Representative Freitas just that I would
like to thank representative Cushman for
the education that I got on this
absolutely thank you
most excitement we've had all day
um other discussion
I seen one okay I'll ask Clark to follow
the wall
this is option pass not to pass yes I'm
sorry
um motion is ought to pass on Senate
bill 35.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel yeah
Representative peloso no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay is not here
uh representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
[Laughter]
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative elberger yes
representative Palmer yes representative
priests yes and representative McDonald
yes
we're glad you're still in the room too
17. I figured everybody could see me
17-2 and one not voting
consent okay the emotion of ought to
pass
is successful 17-2
just a fur to have it on the regular
account
um
The Descendants objective of going on
the consent calendar
I'm sorry
okay yeah so without objection we'll put
it on the consent calendar
okay well it's been a certainly a full
day and I respect I appreciate the fact
you remember remember that I had to be
out by two so 12 minutes to spare
and and who is writing the majority
report for that one
representative Merchants
thank you I missed that correct I'll
write them it's concerning
I'll write the report and by the way
when does the report have to be in well
um sooner the better
uh so so I mean yeah today is the
deadline for the calendar so
representative Weber what would you
think by next Wednesday
there's no there's no house next
Wednesday okay
okay all right okay all right
okay all right thank you
okay so uh that concludes our business
for today uh just to so everyone knows I
have put the rest of the bills on for
next Wednesday we have no hearings left
so next Wednesday we will be considering
all of the other Senate bills to include
this one Senate bill that will be very
quick and easy called Medicaid expansion
probably take just a few minutes but uh
actually probably more than a few but uh
so I we have eight bills left
so anyway thank you all and I'll see you
next Wednesday
foreign